et bien mesdames et messieurs et les
autres s'il y en a bon soir je vais
essayer de ne pas être trop long ce qui
est un exercice difficile en ce qui me
concerne je suis ravi de voir que j'ai
essentiellement des jeunes alors vous
savez les jeunes à l'âge que j'ai c'est
plus jeune que moi donc dans cette salle
non je suis content parce que c'est
évidemment plus vous avez d'année devant
vous et plus normalement vous pourrez
faire quelque chose de ce que je vais
vous raconter je suis parti de l'idée
que j'intervenais dans une fac de
sciences donc je vais être
nécessairement quantitatif donc je vais
vous assommer avec des tas de courbe
mais comme on vous laissera le polycopié
c'est à dire le support un peu plus tard
vous pourriez revenir à tête reposée si
ça vous chante
la présentation est pas toujours aussi
longs en ce qui concerne donc dans un
souci de transparence
une petite planche pour rappeler ce que
je fais l'essentiel de ce qui me fait
vivre et d'être effectivement patrons de
pme
c'est une pme un peu particulière parce
que c'est 30 ingénieurs et grâce à mon
associé à moi la moyenne d'âge dépasse
30 ans sinon ça serait plutôt couches
culottes
on est une trentaine et on s'occupe de
transition bas carbone quand on y arrive
j'ai monté il ya six ans avec l'aide
d'un certain nombre de grandes
entreprises je vous expliquerai pourquoi
la fin un film tant qu un agent en plus
exactement qui traite ou tout juste là
va sortir une espèce de programme
politique idéal ou plus exactement de
programme économique idéal vu de notre
fenêtre avec lequel on espère alimenter
refaire le coup du pacte écologique
alimenter les débats 24 heures par an
sans compter la correction des copies
désagréable je fais effectivement un
cours et enfin il fut un temps parce que
là maintenant ça commence à ressembler à
de l'archéologie
quand on se balade dans mon site c'est
un peu fossilisés puis tellement temps
de m'en occuper mais enfin j'ai
effectivement beaucoup contribué à
essayer de comprendre donc de décrire
ce dont je vais vous parler aujourd'hui
de temps en temps un éditeur me
convainquent j'ai rien de plusieurs
genres d'écrire un bouquin de temps en
temps je me laisse séduire en fait c'est
toujours le même je les aime bien le
dernier c'est surtout le sous titre qui
est important évidemment vous aurez
compris que dans mes tranquille jusqu'en
2100 c'est du second voire du 25e degré
évidemment une partie de ce que je vais
vous raconter ce soir c'est que non
seulement on peut pas dormir jusqu'en
2100 mais on dort déjà plus tranquille à
cause des problèmes que je vais évoquer
devant vous et une partie de ce que je
vais développer ce soir est du reste que
je développe dans ce livre relève de la
dune des fameuses devise shadoks parce
qu'il y en a plein des devis shadoks
l'une d'entre elles étant quand on sait
pas où on va l'important est d'y aller
plus vite possible et une partie de ce
qu'on est en train de faire en ce moment
en ce qui concerne l'énergie relève
extrêmement bien de cette maxime shadoks
alors je vous ai dit je suis bavard
alors comme je suis bavard je vais
prendre une petite précaution qui est de
commencer par les conclusions c'est
normalement c'est tout à fait interdit
dans un devoir de philo
bah moi je vais faire un truc tout à
fait interdit du reste ça reste entre
nous même si c enregistrés j'ai eu six
en philo au bac
donc je vais commencer par la conclusion
la première conclusion c'est que quand
on parle de croissance économique
on parle de croissance de
l'approvisionnement énergétique et quand
l'approvisionnement énergétique on parle
de croissance économique donc monsieur
macron pas plus que monsieur fillon pas
plus que monsieur juppé pas plus que
monsieur montebourg pas plus que
monsieur mélenchon ne ferons en sorte
que le pib en france soit supérieure en
2022 à ce qu'il est en 2017
aucun ne pourra le faire à cause de ce
que je vais vous raconter maintenant
donc la question c'est pas voter pour
celui qui fera revenir la croissance
c'est voter pour celui qui saura le
mieux gérer un univers en contraction
c'est bien comme ça qu'il va falloir
prendre le problème nonobstant tout ce
qu'il a pu promettre et ça n'arrange pas
les choses qu'ils promettent
la deuxième chose très désagréable que
je vais vous exposer ce soir c'est que
pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont suivi des
cours d'économie oublier les cours
d'économie il n'ya pas d'élasticité prix
volumes en ce qui concerne l'énergie
dit autrement c'est pas patient n'a plus
que ça vaut moins cher et qui en a moins
que ça vaut plus cher ça marche pas
comme ça d'accord c'est très désagréable
dans toutes les belles fonctions avec
eux vous savez le prix qui baissent
quand le volume augmenté chez pas quoi
bullshit
en ce qui concerne l'énergie bullshit la
troisième chose que je vais vous montrer
c'est que pour des raisons géologiques
et non pas à cause du de la volonté des
bords locaux susco et autres dans les
pays de l' ocde pour des raisons
géologiques l'approvisionnement dans la
zone des pays dits riches ocde est
contraint à la baisse depuis 2007 et que
c'est le déclencheur direct de tous les
troubles économiques qu'on a connus
depuis et dans ma vision du monde des
élections un peu surprenante que nous
avons connue en 2016
tout ça est lié je vous rappelle
également une petite chose simple mais
que je vais développer aussi sait
qu'historiquement il ya deux siècles on
était 100% vénère donc si on est passé
de 100 % vénère à 80% de cochonneries de
fossiles c'est bien qu'ils avaient une
raison et on va aussi essayer de
comprendre pourquoi
si c'était si simple de rester 100%
renner s'emmerderait pas aujourd'hui à
essayer d'y retourner
on serait resté là où en était un il y
aurait pas de problème le autre chose
que je vais vous montrer c'est que il
n'ya pas de miracle technologique pour
respecter l'accord de paris et que 2° c
monstrueusement récessif faut le faire
peut-être mais en tout cas le faire en
s'imaginant que c'est compatible avec la
hausse du pouvoir d'achat
jamais je parais toutes mes économies
contre celle de qui veut parer
transmissibles à mes enfants que c'est
rigoureusement impossible voilà je y
accueillir 300 personnes prêtes à paris
dans la salle pas de problème je prends
les 300 paris
enfin dernier point qui se rapproche un
peu de ce que j'ai dit au dessus dans un
univers contraint augmenter ce qu'on a
coutume d'appeler le libéralisme
dit autrement la mise en concurrence
l'initiative des acteurs non coordonnés
et c'est ce à quoi le bordel ça ne fait
pas baisser donc d'augmenter la libre
concurrence dans un monde en expansion
c'est parfait pour le consommateur sans
qu'on bute sur des limites physiques
augmentent et la mise en concurrence
dans un monde qui a des limites
physiques
c'est exactement l'inversé que ça fait
ça à crolles bordel je vous dis ça parce
que on a fondé l'europe sur l'idée qu'on
allait faire des choses ensemble pour ne
plus se battre
excellente idée et on est aujourd'hui en
train de confondre la fin et les moyens
la fin c'était pas se battre le moyen ça
a été de faire du commerce hyundai
puisqu'on fait du commerce va
libéraliser partout et aujourd'hui
l'europe confond la fin ne pas se taper
dessus avec le moyen qui ai je fait
sauter la concurrence partout et tout le
temps et c'est ça mon objectif ultime
est comme ça tout le monde est content
non si aujourd'hui on veut la paix il
faut faire l'exact inverse dans ce genre
d'affaires mon programme économique
idéal que je vous exposerai tout à fait
à la fin donc ce n'est pas de la
physique je vous préviens ça c'est tout
à fait de l'idéologie
en gros inclut le fait d'abord que si
dès qu'on cherche à violer la loi de
conservation de l'énergie où la règle de
trois on se vautre rats et aujourd'hui
tous les politiques que je connais en
première approximation cherche à faire
ça tous la deuxième chose qu'il faut
avoir en tête c'est que il n'est pas
légitime de défendre une approche coûts
bénéfices en matière d'environnement
dit autrement si je n'agis pas je vais
perdre trois points de pib alors que si
j'agis en perd que 0 foutaise aussi déjà
personne n'est capable de prévoir le pib
dans dix ans six ans aurait donc les
gens sont encore moins capable
il ya de bonnes raisons à ça tu reste
donc les engeances ou encore moins
capable de savoir qui est la fraction du
pib qu'on peut perdre si l'environnement
est détériorée en fait si vous poussez
le raisonnement à son à son à la
caricature
s'il ya plus d'environnements du tout je
suis pris de la planète terre est plus
de pib du tout donc une chose absolument
certaine c'est que sans environnement ya
pas de pib donc combien de pib je perds
si j'entame l'environnement n'importe
quoi entre 0 et 100 %
comme ça c'est une copie que j'accepte
sinon non et enfin ça signifie dans cet
univers en contraction donc que votre
pouvoir d'achat et le mien va descendre
c'est bien ça qui va se passer
eh bien ça signifie que si on veut
continuer à donner des emplois aux gens
il faut passer d'un système qui pousse à
la consommation un système qui pousse à
la reconstruction
parce qu'en fait notre système
aujourd'hui notre notre mode de vie
il est totalement incompatible enfin on
peut pas maintenir la paix sociale dans
un contexte de décrue rapide des
combustibles fossiles avec les
infrastructures qui existent telles
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui ça marche pas
il ya trop de monde dans les bureaux pas
assez dans les champs etc
enfin tout a pas de trucs trop de monde
dans les villes passées dans le tissu
rural
bref ya tout un tas de trucs qui
organisait de travers si on veut
résister dans un cadre de paix sociale
et donc il faut tout reconstruire
et en fait les deux degrés en gros ça
vise à ça ça vise à tout reconstruire
voilà donc ça c'est les conclusions
maintenant ceux qui ont soif doivent
partir et pour les autres on va rentrer
dans le vif du sujet c'est qu'en france
la remise de l'énergie il ya aussi un
prof très connu là qui s'appelle
foucault beaucoup plus connu que moi 7
millions d'élèves à chaque fois qu'il
fait court et foucault il a jamais posé
cette question mais il pourrait alors
vous pourrez demander à pujadas de la
poser à ségolène royal
qu'est-ce que l'énergie ainsi pujadas a
opposé à ségolène royal dur et je vous
fiche mon billet que l comme tous ceux
qui ont précédé serait pas foutu de
donner la bonne réponse mais c'est pas
grave
qu'est-ce que l'énergie alors vous
pouvez faire le test
si vous demandez aux gens qu est-ce que
l'énergie toute personne dans la salle
qui un jour à payer une facture
d'électricité va me répondre ça de
manière pavlovienne l'énergie c'est une
facture je reçois une facture
d'électricité tous les deux mois je
reçois une facture de gaz
les deux ou trois mois éventuellement je
vais penser au plein de ma voiture si je
fais un petit effort et encore plus
éventuellement je vais penser au plein
de la cuve à fuel si je fais un petit
effort mais ils ont globalement c'est
une facture d'électricité ou de gaz
alors c'est pas font que ça peut être
une réponse
et à partir du moment où on prend cette
entrée on a perdu par construction
pourquoi on a perdu par construction
parce que si vous pensez facture vous
allez penser part dans les dépenses et
dur et je vais vous poser tout de suite
une question qui dans cette salle et
locataires
qui dans cette salle est locataire et ne
connaît pas le montant de son loyer
pas une main qui dans cette salle paye
ses factures d'électricité ou de gaz qui
dans cette salle ne connaît pas le
montant qu'il ya sur ses factures
voilà c'est bien la preuve que dès que
vous pensez facture vous dites c'est
secondaire
c'est une petite partie de mes dépenses
donc je m'en occuperai quand j'ai le
temps et si j'ai pas le temps je m'en
occupe pas c'est très exactement à ça
que nous amène la proche comptable vous
avez ici un graphique qui vous donnent
la part de l'énergie alors brut primes
rcd baril de pétrole s'est pas des
carburants raffinés
rapporté au pib c'est à dire en fait aux
revenus puisque le pib est une somme de
revenus donc c'est la part de l'énergie
dans les dépenses des agents économiques
vous voyez ces quelques pourcents
quelques pourcents bonjour sauf que si
vous faites ce raisonnement dit ces
quelques pourcents je m'en fous il est
aussi ridicule parce que tout le reste
en dépend que si vous dites à ma
cervelle ces 2 % de mon poids donc si on
m'enlève la moitié de ma cervelle c'est
vraiment pas un sujet je perds un pour
cent d'efficacité d'accord non sujet
absolu et ben c'est aussi ridicule de
penser que parce que l'énergie fait 5 %
de nos dépenses
en fait c'est un non sujet absolu parce
que ce que je vais vous montrer
maintenant c'est que l'énergie tout le
reste en dépend tout le reste en dépend
donc si vous enlevez votre cervelle
votre corps ne fonctionne plus si
j'enlève l'énergie notre société ne
pourrait plus est le fait que ça soit 1
2 5 ou 10 % ou 60 dans la dent en parle
des dépenses
c'est juste pas le sujet vous verrez que
si on doit raisonner en part de dépenses
et corrigé d'une manière pertinente en
fait l'énergie devrait nous coûter 500
fois plus cher que les salaires comme ça
qu'on devrait compter si on était
orthodoxe c'est une facture je suis sûr
qu'il ya aussi quelques personnes dans
la salle qui aurait comme réflexe
pavlovien ainsi qu'est ce que l'énergie
ah je sais pas mais faut l'économiser
comme quoi la meilleure énergie est
celle qu'on ne consomme pas eh bien
c'est faux archi faux
si on avait résonné comme ça depuis 1800
votre pouvoir d'achat sera resté celui
d'un paysan c'est bien parce qu'on a
consommé de plus en plus d'énergie que
votre pouvoir d'achat à monter donc la
meilleure énergie c'est pas du tout
celle qu'on ne consomme pas
historiquement sur les deux derniers
siècles
c'est celle qu'on consomme entre
c'est bien celle-là la bonne énergie
c'est bien parce qu'on a consommé de
plus en plus d'énergie qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez des billets easyjet à 50 euros
qui n'a jamais pris l'avion à cette
salle pas nombreux donc c'est voilà si
la meilleure énergie est celle qu'on ne
consomme est pas tous les gens qui n'ont
pas levé la main n'ont jamais pris
l'avion
d'accord donc en fait c'est pas comme ça
qu'on a résonné historiquement c'est
peut-être ça qu'il faut penser
aujourd'hui mais c'est pas comme ça
qu'on a résonné historiquement après
vous pouvez essayer de poser la question
à un philosophe alors pas moi qui ait
une seule note mais un vrai et à ce
moment le philosophe pas vous dire
l'énergie c'est quelque chose qui me
rend dynamique
j'en suis rempli un matin où je suis en
forme le philosophe a raison et les deux
autres ont tort car comme le savent
normalement un certain nombre des gens
qui sont assis sur ses bancs l'énergie
c'est par définition en physique ce qui
caractérise de changement d'état d'un
système c'est donc ce qui quantifie la
transformation du monde sait ça en fait
l'énergie cse qui quantifie la
transformation du monde plus le monde se
transforme plus y'a d'énergie plus il ya
d'énergie plus le monde se transforme
c'est aussi simple que ça dit autrement
dit j'utilise beaucoup d'énergie et
c'est propre c'est impossible par
construction puisque si vous utilisez
beaucoup d'énergie vous allez beaucoup
transformé et vous ne pourrez pas
laisser les toilettes dans l'état dans
lequel vous les avez trouvés en entrant
j'ai juste pas possible vous aurait
changé quelque chose
une énergie propre en fait vous vous
rendrez compte quand on regarde les
chiffres que c'est essentiellement une
énergie qui est utilisé à des doses
infinitésimales
et à ce moment n'importe quelle énergie
est propre dès qu'on cesse de l'utiliser
à des zones infinitésimale n'importe
quelle énergie est sale si on était 5
millions d'êtres humains sur terre
aujourd'hui je vous assure que le diesel
et le charbon serait propre
parfaitement propre d'accord on pourra
utiliser vivent tous comme à
d'américains ayant personne sur terre
avec du charbon du pétrole autant qu'on
veut il y aurait aucun sujet
environnemental global ni du côté des
ressources ni du côté de la pollution
zéro absolument aucun al'inverse si vous
devez faire des panneaux solaires pour
assurer vingt mille kilowatts heure par
personne et par an à 7 milliards d'êtres
humains je peux vous assurer que ce
n'est pas propre et en part propre du
tout et probablement pire qu'une partie
des choses que ça remplacerait donc le
donc l'idée qu'il peut exister de
l'énergie propre
c'est une idée qui est à slogans
sympathique
malheureusement contredit quand on
commence à regarder les chiffres
et en fait il n'existe pas plus
d'énergie propre que d'énergie verte ou
que d'énergie argenté clignotantes
l'énergie c'est la transformation points
alors que ce soit la transformation est
facile à illustrer pour les gens qui ont
du mal avec les équations physique en
leur disant et c'est lié au changement
donc des quelque chose change et
l'énergie donc si vous changez une
température une vitesse une forme une
composition chimique le déplacement d'un
corps dans un champ de potentielle
gravitationnelle et c'est une
composition atomique ou que vous faites
intérieur et interagir de la matière et
du rayonnement quelque part dans toutes
ces transformations ya de l'énergie
et si inversement de l'énergie se
manifestent vous aurez une de ces
transformations ou une autre mais vous
aurez quelque chose qui va se passer
dans le monde physique
j'aurais pu vous mettre à changement de
phase il ya quelque chose qui se passe
dès que vous avez de l'énergie qui
intervient donc je leur ai dit compter
la transformation ses comptes et
l'énergie compter l'énergie ses comptes
et la transformation dire qu'un homme
consomme beaucoup d'énergie en fait est
un terme impropre puisque vous ne buvez
pas le pétrole enfin je vous le
recommande pas vous ne mangez du charbon
que du spécial et en cas de flatulences
mais sinon l'autre vous ne mangez pas et
on vous dit qu'il faut pas mettre les
doigts dans la prise électrique et on a
raison donc vous ne consommez pas
d'électricité en direct en fait dire
qu'un homme consomme beaucoup d'énergie
c'est juste dire qu'il a un grand parc
de machines à sa disposition qui lui va
consommer de l'énergie c'est ça que ça
veut dire consommer beaucoup de beaucoup
une énergie donc dire que la
consommation d'énergie augmente c'est en
fait dire que le parc de machines par
personne aux banques
c'est ça que ça veut dire énergie ces
parcs de machines
c'est comme ça qu'il faut comprendre la
suite de ce que je vais vous raconter
historiquement la machine c'était nous
donc le premier convertisseur d'énergie
que l'homme a eu à sa disposition
s'était lui-même sa femme quand il lui
parler gentiment et qu'il le ferait une
bague pour la saint valentin
vous avez ici donc un convertisseur
d'énergie qui peut se livrer à un
exercice parfaitement vu futile soit dit
en passant qui consiste à aller pas très
loin vers l'est et à monter sur une
montagne
imaginons alors quand on est à paris
cocorico on peut faire monter sur la
tour eiffel et pour l'exercice qui va
suivre on peut imaginer qu'on monte six
fois dans la journée sur la tour eiffel
à pied 1 en prenant l'ascenseur pas
triché et bien si vous faites ce genre
d'exercice donc vous prenez votre propre
corps que vous le faites lutter contre
le chandail national
on vous le monter en altitude et bien le
fait de le hisser sur 2022 dénivelé va
vous permettre de fournir une énergie
totalement ridicule estime d'un demi
kilo watt heure donc un homme qui
utilise ses muscles sur une journée est
capable de transformer l'environnement à
hauteur de radeaux me kilowattheure
alors il peut ne pas monter sur une
montagne ce qu'elle n'a aucun intérêt
il peut par exemple pédaler comme
charlton heston dans sur les greens là
au début pour faire briller une ampoule
qui est déjà mieux
mais du coup il va utiliser ses jambes
et bien un homme qui utilise ses jambes
maximum maximorum de ce qui peut donner
dans une journée
un demi kilo watt heure ce qui revient à
dire soit dit en passant que la
puissance moyenne est de l'ordre de 50
watts en puissance moyenne de vos jambes
50 watts au terrible à regarder la
puissance de votre aspirateur
regardez combien de personnes il
faudrait faire pédaler remplacer
l'aspirateur 50 watts pas beaucoup
imaginons que vous faisiez ça un jour
sur deux je vous le dis autrement pour
ceux d'entre vous qui aiment la corse
une étape du gr20 par jour tous les
jours
1er janvier au 31 décembre parce que
c'est peut-être plus sympa que de venir
la fac cheveux d'ange l'a dit et bien à
la fin d'année vous aurez fournit 100
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique donc
un homme qui fait un travail de force
sur l'année avec ses jambes qui est
capable de transformer l'environnement
parce que si cette énergie et
communiquer une machine à creuser à
remonter h pourquoi 100 kilowatts heure
l'homme en question surtout s'il
s'appelle monsieur schwarzenegger jeune
peut aussi prendre une pelle est remonté
de la terre pour faire un grand trou et
à ce moment ci des caisses 15 tonnes de
terre dans la journée six mètres cubes
est pas mal eh bien il va fournir une
énergie encore plus ridicule dix fois
plus ridicule en fait de 0,01
kilowattheure travers ce genre d'effort
et donc une fois un jour sur deux sur
toute l'année
10 kilowatts heure donc un nouveau
travail de force 10 à 100 kilowatts
heure d'énergie mécanique sur une année
à peu près tout il se trouve que 10
kilowatts heure d'énergie thermique pour
le coup pas mécanique
c'est ce que j'obtiens en faisant brûler
un litre de pétrole
un seul litre de pétrole ridicule ou
faussement cher comme vous le savez un
euro et quelques litres de carburant
scandale atteinte au pouvoir d'achat
savons rien ça ne vaut strictement rien
qu'en vous savez qu'un litre de pétrole
permet de fournir quelques kilowatts
heure d'énergie mécanique qui vont
remplacer 10 à 100 jours de travail de
force d'un homme l'énergie ne vaut rien
moins que rien absolument rien parce que
si on devait égaliser les coûts en
fonction de la capacité à transformer
l'environnement
à ce moment mon kilowattheure mécanique
humain me coûte quelques centaines à
quelques milliers d'euros si je paye mon
convertisseur au smic dans mon home au
smic en face de ça la machine me fournit
le même service de transformation de
l'environnement pour un coût marginal de
15 centimes
dit autrement ça me coûte quelques
centaines à quelques milliers de fois
moins cher de faire appel à la machine
plutôt qu'à l'homme pour transformer
l'environnement
alors je vous renverse le truc ça veut
dire que si les entreprises
comptabilisée
l'énergie à hauteur de sa capacité de
transformation et les hommes à hauteur
de la capacité de transformation et bien
les entreprises même suisse devrait
multiplier le coût de l'énergie dans
leur charge par 1000 pour que ça
devienne comparable aux salaires et là
je peux vous assurer que on s'occuperait
de ce qui compte vraiment là on
s'occuperait de ce qu'ils comptent
vraiment aujourd'hui on dit bon c'est
les salaires le plus important c'est ça
qui compte vraiment pour faire du pib
non pas du tout ce qui compte pour faire
du pib c'est ça mieux encore
imaginons maintenant qu'on prenne un
esclave alors il ya peu n'a probablement
quelques endroits dans lion mal connus
où les gens sont ravis d'être dans ce
genre de conditions
moi je ne connais pas mais en général
esclaves c'est pas une vocation de
jeunesse donc les gens qui sont esclaves
vous devez aller les chercher contre
leur volonté ça va vous coûter de
l'argent les empêcher de [ __ ] le camp
ça va vous coûter de l'argent les
empêcher de vous trucider ça va vous
coûter de l'argent et les nourrir et les
vêtir pour les empêcher de mourir ça va
vous coûter de l'argent face de ça vous
avez leur travail et bien si vous faites
le calcul de ce que vous coûte
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique
venant d'un esclave
même ça ça va vous coûter 10 à 100 fois
plus cher que la machine qui a le bon
goût de ne pas se mettre en grève de
travailler toute la nuit sans rouspéter
pourquoi voulez vous vous emmerdez à
utiliser des esclaves dans un monde où
il ya du pétrole
eh bien vous ne l'utilisez pas ce qui a
supprimé l'esclavagisme dans ma vision
du monde c'est pas le fait que votre
code génétique est considérablement
améliorée par rapport à celui des
générations qui vous ont précédés ya
deux siècles je pense que vous êtes
aussi beau et aussi mauvais aussi
altruiste et aussi égoïste que les gens
il ya deux siècles exactement pareil par
contre ce qui a changé c'est que le
pétrole est beaucoup plus efficace pour
obtenir un service que vos semblables et
donc vous emmerdez pas à contraindre nos
semblables
le jour où l'énergie abondante
commencera à se contracter
les rapports entre les hommes
recommenceront à se tendre et en fait ça
commence déjà à petite échelle
ça commence déjà à petite échelle
pour le moment on vit la partie a sans
doute du mariage fausse tiens à vous
rappeler le mariage faustien c'est au
début c'est génial râle oubliées comme
disait l'autre
et puis après faut payer donc là pour le
moment on est dans la partie rallo vit
alors dans la portière à l'obliqué ce
qui se passe
il se passe que l'approvisionnement
énergétique par therrien est passé en un
siècle
2500 kilowatts heure par personne et par
an en gros à plus de 20000 et cet
accroissement s'est fait en empilant les
énergies les unes sur les autres
contrairement à une idée couramment
répandue les énergies ne se substitue
pas l s'empilent
historiquement on a commencé par
utiliser de la biomasse sur laquelle on
a rajouté le charbon sur laquelle on a
rajouté de pétrole sur laquelle on a
rajouté le gaz sur laquelle on a rajouté
l'hydroélectricité le nucléaire et les
nouvelles énergies renouvelables corps
il n'y a pas de cannibalisme à large
échelle 0 on a rajouté le charbon oui
que charbon par personne depuis qu'on
s'en serve à jamais des crues
évidemment comme il ya plus en plus de
personnes le charbon tout court encore
moins des crues il a raison à cela c'est
que les deux tiers du charbon exploités
dans le monde servent à produire de
l'électricité je vous montrerai un peu
plus tard que l'électricité au charbon
et de très loin la première le premier
mode de production électrique dans le
monde de très très loin le pétrole est
venu sera jeté par dessus parce que le
pétrole ne sert pas ou très
marginalement à produire de
l'électricité le pétrole sert
essentiellement à déplacer des objets et
des marchandises le pétrole et l'énergie
de la mondialisation par excellence il
demain matin je devais supprimer le
pétrole dans le monde
non seulement lyon et paris mouraient de
faim puisqu'il y aura plus
d'approvisionnement en nourriture eau et
camions pour ça non mais si je supprime
le pétrole demain matin je peux vous
dire la moitié des urbains en france
meurt de faim absolument certain
donc le faire donc le pétrole sert à
déplacer des personnes et des
marchandises et pas à produire de
l'électricité
envoyez donc le gaz et mâcha et puis
tout en haut là il ya le truc dont on
nous rebat les oreilles toute la journée
je vous rappelle à ce propos une petite
conclusion simple que ceux d'entre vous
qui connaissent bien les médias n'auront
pas de mal à reprendre à leur compte
il n'y a strictement aucun rapport entre
l'importance d'un sujet dans le journal
et son importance dans la vie réelle
aucun il y a un lien extrêmement fort
entre l'importance d'un sujet dans le
journal et le nombre de communiqués de
presse qui ont été envoyés ça c'est
absolument certain
il n'y a strictement aucun rapport entre
l'importance réelle d'un phénomène dans
le monde et sa pagination dans le
journal au cas alors c'est très
désagréable de vous dire ça c'est une
autre manière de vous dire que dès qu'il
s'agit de chiffres
le journal n'est pas une source
opposable enfin ceux d'entre vous qui
publie dans les revues à comité de
lecture dans cette salle de sa bien
sinon ce serait pas emmerdé à faire des
revues à comité de lecture on se
contenterait de publier des trucs dans
le journal ce qu'on ne fait pas donc il
n'y a strictement aucune fiabilité
quantitative par principe dans le
journal certains journalistes
travaillent bien publier des trucs qui
en général sont vraies d'autres
travaillent comme des cochons ou n'y
comprennent rien et publie en général
d'être qui s'en faut et c'est donc pas
par précaution dès que vous ne
connaissez pas le journaliste qui va
publier quelque chose ou qui va émettre
un avis à la radio à la télé ou dans un
support écrit ce qu'il vous dit pas
défaut vous ne pouvez pas le croire
c'est très désagréable mais c'est comme
ça vous pouvez pas sur les chiffres
vous pouvez pas et si le journal
je vous montrerai un peu plus tard ce
que le journal aurait dû faire s'ils
avaient dû refléter l'importance réelle
des phénomènes dans le monde alors il
n'empêche que pour le moment je vous le
redis l'approvisionnement énergétique
par personne dans le monde est grimpé à
environ 20 milles personnes 1000
kilowatts heure par dons par an ça
revient à dire que nous sommes tous
devenus superman est super woman pour de
vraies touches auprès des dards des
villes et les stingers enfin peu importe
en ce sens que notre capacité productive
grâce aux machines puisque l'énergie
c'est les machines je vous le redis
notre capacité productive
grâce aux machines a été multiplié par
un facteur 2 100 par personne par
rapport à l'époque où nous n'avions que
nos bras et aux jambes
voilà ce que l'énergie a fait pour nous
est à multiplier la capacité productive
moyenne d'un individu sur terre par deux
sens et donc elle a multiplié votre
pouvoir d'achat par deux sens c'est
aussi con que ça va parce que pour
consommer faut produire pour ne pas
acheter des lunettes compas été
produites pouvez pas acheter des
chemises compass a été produite vous
pouvez pas acheter des chaises et les
tables qu'on pas été produites et vous
pouvez pas acheter un bifteck cas pas
être d'une vache qui a pas été élevés
donc pas de production pas de
consommation de la consommation de la
production et ce qui s'est passé dans le
monde
sur les deux derniers siècles enfin sur
le siècle et demi c'est que la
consommation par personne a été
multiplié par un facteur qui se baladent
n'importe où entre 50 et 150 grâce à
l'énergie
si vous prenez le prix réel d'un objet
qui existe aujourd'hui et qui existait
déjà il ya un siècle et demi pour une
chemise par exemple ou une mètres carrés
de logement ou une table et bien vous
vous rendrez compte que exprimé en
heures de travail
le prix de cet objet a fait l'objet
d'une division par n'importe quoi entre
50 et 200 n'importe quoi et c'est le
facteur multiplicatif qui s'est appliqué
au pouvoir d'achat et c'est pas les
promesses de hollande de sarkozy ou de
qui on veut qu'ils ont fait ça c'est
qu'ils omettent heures c'est le fait que
mère nature nous a donné un stock
alors voilà un tout petit échantillon de
nos esclaves des temps modernes je peux
vous le dire autrement
grâce à ce facteur de 1 à 2 sens entre
la puissance de nos carcasse et la
puissance des machines qu'on a à notre
disposition nous vivons tous comme
l'ancien troyen l'ancienne rome où
l'ancien athènes où vous savez que vous
aviez quelques dizaines ou centaines de
milliers de citoyens libres assis sur
une armée d'esclaves donc on nous rebat
les oreilles avec la démocratie antique
pas la démocratie antique
c'était un tout petit morceau de la
population de l'époque eh bien là c'est
pareil
les sept milliards d'individus sont
devenus un tout petit morceau de la
population 199 2 centièmes de la
population étant constitué de machines
et nos esclaves à nous des temps
modernes qui nous permettent d'avoir du
temps libre et de la croissance pour la
démocratie
alors voilà comme je disais tout à
l'heure un petit échantillon de nos
esclaves des temps modernes qui en plus
sont la très bonne idée et par rapport
aux esclaves des temps anciens de ne
même pas nous faire concurrence sur les
surfaces disponibles sur terre car les
esclaves des temps anciens devait manger
sinon vous perdez votre esclave et quand
il s'agissait des animaux de trait il
devait manger aussi donc il nous ait
concurrence sur le sol les esclaves des
temps modernes nous font même pas
concurrence sur le sol il me laisse tout
le sol pour nous qui mangent du sous sol
or ils mangent du charbon du pétrole du
gaz et l'uranium dont qu'il mange de
sous sol il y en a quelques-uns qui
mange un peu de soles un peu de biomasse
à peu de chutes de hausse assez il faut
mettre des barrages dans les alpes un
peu de soleil
enfin globalement ils mangent du sous
sol et il représente l'équivalent de 200
personnes en fin de 2 200 carcasse
additionnel on va dire partez rien
envoyé deux mondial en france on est
plutôt à 6 ans je vous le dit autrement
la consommation énergétique annuelle
d'un français est de l'ordre de 70
kilowatt heure cinquante mille ans
consommation directe en france dix
villes à travers les biens importés et
dit autrement encore tous les gens qui
sont dans cette salle vivent en moyenne
comme si il avait 6 ans esclaves à leur
disposition donc la vérité politiquement
indicible de ce que je suis en train de
vous raconter c'est que le smicard
français vit comme un nabab
il s'en rend pas compte et en plus il
n'est pas content parce qu'il ya des
mieux que smicard qui ont plus que lui
et la raison pour laquelle il n'est pas
content c'est à cause de la malédiction
de tocqueville acquis expliqué qu'en
démocratie dès que quelqu'un aurait bio
vous vous seriez pas content donc la
seule solution de résoudre le problème
ou la malédiction de tocqueville en
démocratie c'est de faire un d'irak
c'est tout le monde exactement la même
chose en ce moment c'est plus une
démocratie
donc c'est compliqué
mais les communistes ont essayé ça
marche pas bien donc le voilà mais c'est
vraiment ça le sujet aujourd'hui le
smicard français vit comme un nabab
grâce à ces esclaves des temps modernes
il a 40 mètres carrés chauffer toute
l'année il a un carrosse tiré par 60
chevaux dans son garage il a les jeux du
cirque en permanence dans son salon ila
à manger du bifteck à tous les repas etc
en fait il vit comme un nabab par
rapport à ce qui était de paysans
français d'il ya deux siècles qui
avaient une espérance de vie à la
naissance de 25 ans et qui faisait 1,5
km par jour en moyenne
prenez pas de vacances n'avait jamais vu
autre chose que sa région c'était je
peux vous assurer le smicard français
vit comme un nabab
c'est une vérité politiquement indicible
j'en suis bien conscient et
malheureusement essayé de violer cette
réalité physique ça marchera pas donc il
y comme adama mais même ça c'est pas
durable alors comme on n'est pas un sur
terre tu alors je vous ai montré par
personne et qu'on est de plus en plus
nombreux et bien l'approvisionnement
énergétique tout court a augmenté
évidemment extrêmement rapidement
vous l'avez ici graduée avec une unité
très barbare qui s'appelle millions de
tonnes équivalent pétrole
alors la tonne équivalent pétrole est
une unité qu aime bien les énergéticiens
enfin les gens comme moi qui font des
calculs d'ordre de grandeur
parce que ça permet d'exprimer la
consommation d'un individu avec un des
petits nombres 60000 kilowattheure c'est
beaucoup et si je vous convertissez en
joules je vais encore me récupérer 6 0
de plus ça va commencer à faire vraiment
beaucoup
la tonne équivalent de pétrole c'est
11600 kilowattheure donc un français ces
quatre tonnes équivalent pétrole 4
comprend encore si je compte si je sais
compter jusqu'à dix chars il va même si
je sais compter jusqu'à 5 donc c'est
plus pratique d'utiliser ce genre
d'unité regardez bien l'évolution de
chaque énergie et voici un des résultats
que j'en retiens
j'ai regardé pour la consommation
mondiale d'énergie donc ce graphique là
où on en était en 2015 où on en était en
2000 et j'ai regardé quelle est l
accroissement le plus important que
j'avais eu enfin quelques paquets
l'accroissement j'avais pour chaque
énergie entre 2000 et 2015 est le
résultat de ce calcul est lancée
toujours des millions de tonnes et
rivalland pétrole et donc la barre la
plus haute ici représente l'énergie qui
a le plus augmenté sur les 15 dernières
années
puis la deuxième barre la plus haute
représente l'énergie qui a le plus
augmenté juste après etc
et alors là vous voyez que l'énergie qui
a le plus augmenté sur les 15 dernières
années où paraît-il on a beaucoup
investi dans les zrr
c est de très loin le charbon le charbon
sur cette période a augmenté plus de 25
fois plus que le solaire
donc si le journal avaient fait
correctement son boulot sur les 15
dernières années pour un article vous
parlant du solaire il aurait dû vous en
servir 25 parlant du charbon voilà ce
qu'il aurait dû faire s'ils avaient
correctement fait son boulot je crois
pas que beaucoup d'entre vous dans la
salle élus des journaux dans lesquels
c'était comme ça que ça se passait la
raison à cela je le redis c'est que le
charbon sert à faire de l'électricité
vous avez ici l'évolution de la
production électrique mondiale alors
attention là c'est pas des
kilowattheures d'énergie primaire c'est
le comprendre l'environnement c'est des
kilowattheures d'énergie électrique
c'est kilowattheure électrique
discriminés par mode de production
alors aujourd'hui nous produisons c'est
un fait du hasard que ce soit le même
chiffre
vingt-deux mille milliards de
kilowattheure électrique par an dans le
monde 22 villes en 1945 la production
électrique mondiale était de l'ordre de
la production électrique française
aujourd'hui en 1945
l'ordre de grandeur de la production
électrique mondiale c'était 500
térawattheures 500 milliards de
kilowattheure électrique
c'est à dire l'ordre de grandeur de la
production électrique française
aujourd'hui donc l'explosion électrique
est un fait marquant de la deuxième
moitié du xxème siècle même pas de la
première vous mêmes mois somme n'est
dans un monde dans lequel l'électricité
s'obtient comme on respire
c'est extrêmement récents dans
l'histoire des hommes extrêmement
récents dans l'histoire des hommes
alors cette électricité avec quoi la
fais ton est bien d'abord avec du
charbon 40 % d'électricité dans le monde
est faite avec du charbon retenait
encore un chiffre impressionnant il y a
dans le monde 30 fois plus de centrales
à charbon que deux centrales nucléaires
en france 30 fois plus 1800 gigawatts de
puissance installée en charge
dans le monde 60 gigawatts de puissance
installée en nucléaire en france j'y
reviendrai tout à l'heure l'accord de
paris et les deux degrés et qu'on a
célébré en s'embrassant sur la bouche
eh bien il suppose que dans les trente
cinq ans qui viennent c'est à dire
qu'avant que les plus jeunes dans cette
salle et mon âge
eh bien il suppose qu'on ait mis à la
ferraille la totalité des centrales à
charbon dans le monde
la totalité donc pour la moitié part
d'un pour cent la totalité et pour
énerver tous tout de suite ceux qui
disent que les nerfs en afrique c'est
génial je rappelle quand même que de
rajouter des nerfs en afrique ne
supprime pas des centrales à charbon en
chine où en allemagne c'est peut-être
très bien de le faire mais ça ne
supprime pas les centrales à charbon en
chine ou en allemagne ou aux états unis
donc la totalité des centrales à charbon
dans le monde je le répète doit être
doit être fait railler d'ici à 2050 si
on veut avoir une petite chance de
parvenir au 2° il ya pas que ça à faire
un jour assure donc il ya au moins un
ordre de grandeur à avoir en tête quand
on parle du charbon un kilowattheure à
kg c'est assez simple pour faire un kilo
watt heure d'électricité au charbon il
faut émettre 1 kg de co2 en moyenne
mondiale
retenez autre chose qui est intéressant
à savoir quand vous faites de
l'électricité au charbon ou que vous la
faites au nucléaire dans les deux cas de
figure vous avez une machine de carnot à
vous faites de la chaleur et avec ça
vous fait un cycle sur ce shoot sur ce
froide vapeur et alternateurs les
rendements moyens dans le monde sont les
mêmes
donc quand vous utilisez du charbon
s'est même pareil que quand vous
utilisez du nucléaire les deux tiers de
la chaleur servent à chauffer les petits
oiseaux nucléaire et pas
particulièrement diaboliques ni
particulièrement efficace ou inefficaces
de ce point de vue il est dans la norme
exactement comme le charbon et si vous
montrez un aéroréfrigérants à un
américain ou un allemand son réflexe
n'est pas de penser nucléaire c'est de
penser charbon parce que c'est juste
caractéristiques d'une centrale en bord
de rivière fin d'une centrale thermique
en bourgogne
après on peut faire de l'électricité
avec du gaz c'est encore 400 grammes de
co2 par kilowattheure donc c'est à 0 il
ya eu un il ya dix ans un mouvement
signifie qu'entre 15 ans plus tôt un
mouvement significatif de climato
scepticisme chez les gaziers qui ont été
très contrarié d'apprendre que le gaz
tout naturel qu'il soit pouvait causer
du changement climatique le signal est
naturel ça peut pas faire de mal
vous assure donc en france en tout cas
je peux vous assurer que les pétroliers
stricto sensu total pour ne pas les
nommer ne n'ont jamais été pris en
flagrant délit de climato-scepticisme ça
fait 15 ans que je fréquente ces gens là
j'ai jamais trouvé un cadre dirigeant de
total climato sceptiques
par contre chez les gaziers j'en ai
ramassé à l'appel lui des explications à
laquelle je pense c'est celle là comme
le gaz naturel c'est quand même
contrariant convient de vous expliquer
derrière que vous n'êtes pas du bon côté
de la barrière on fait encore un peu
d'électricité avec du pétrole et après
les deux grands modes décarbonés de
production électrique c'est
l'hydroélectricité et le nucléaire donc
quand vous quand on vous dit soit dit en
passant que le renouvelable augmente
dans le monde
ne pensez pas immédiatement éolien et
solaire pensez immédiatement
hydroélectricité et là encore la
propreté est toujours quelque chose qui
peut se discuter le plus grand lac de
barrage dans le monde il fait la
superficie d'un département français
cinq mille kilomètres carrés
ces propos c'est pas propre pour faire
le barrage des trois gorges on a déplacé
un million de personnes 150 milles à
tchernobyl ces trois pouces est pas
propre
bah c'est une question de point de vue
ça se discute et enfin au vous avez les
nouvelles renouvelables qui sont pas si
décarbonés que ça quand vous faites du
solaire stockée sur batterie et je dois
ça un avis qui travaille aussi au lit tu
n es bien le total des émissions liées à
la production du kilowattheure sur le
panneau parce qu'il faut bien le faire
le panneau et des émissions liées au
stockage dans une batterie ça se
baladent quelque part entre 100 et 200
grammes de co2 s'est pas complètement
ridicule et s'est pas complètement 0
voilà donc voilà avec quoi on fait
aujourd'hui de l'électricité et 65% de
la production électrique mondiale et
fossiles alors dollars une conclusion
aussi qu'il faut garder en tête les
l'électricité comme du reste hydrogène
ne sont pas d énergie qu on trouve
spontanément dans la nature enfin
jusqu'au jour où on sera capable de
brancher l'accélérateur du cern sur les
éclairs d'orage mais on n'y est pas
encore donc pour le moment l'électricité
c'est pas une énergie primaire et
l'hydrogène non plus il faut les faire
avec quelque chose eh bien les énergies
finale sont aussi propres que l'énergie
primaire avec lac avec laquelle on les
fait pas mieux
pas pire si vous allez en allemagne 50 %
de charbon pour utiliser une voiture
électrique ça vous fait in fine et
autant de co2 et autant de particules
fines que si vous utilisez une voiture à
essence c'est pas mieux
c'est un bon moyen de passer du pétrole
qui est en train de manquer au charbon
qui vantent pas ça résout absolument pas
de problème de co2 est pas non plus nos
problèmes de particules et pas non plus
de problème de destruction d'écosystèmes
parce que les mines allemandes sont des
mines à ciel ouvert qui sont les pires
saloperies qu'on puisse imaginer pour
l'environnement si vous allez en chine
passer de la voiture à pétrole à la
voiture électrique ça vous augmente les
émissions de co2 donc quand monsieur
ghosn tout polytechnicien qu'il soit il
est plus intelligent que moi en plus
parce que lui les corps des mines moi je
suis autodidacte mais quand monsieur
ghosn disait électrique égale zéro co2
c'était un fieffé menteur
évidemment aussi sale que la manière de
faire l'électricité et dans le monde en
moyenne la voiture électrique n'évite
pas de co2 non je le redis au risque
d'être un peu lourd dans le monde
en moyenne la voiture électrique n'évite
pas de co2 ça n'empêche pas un certain
nombre d'investisseurs de concerne de
considérer que quand vous émettez des
obligations pour électrifier les
véhicules en chine c'est green bombe
dans les empêche pas vous
savait également que la france est un
pays tout nucléaire qui n'a jamais
entendu que la france était un pays tout
nucléaire
pas une main donc il ya plus de gens qui
ont entendu ça que de gens qui savent
combien sur leur facture d'électricité
j'ai mis ici oui c'est normal c'est tout
à fait normal
je vous ai mis ici une segmentation de
la consommation électrique française
alors je le redis c'est des machines 1
selon l'endroit où se trouve la machine
la graduation ici c'est des
kilowattheures des milliards de
kilowattheures d'énergie finale donc
celle qui alimente les machines pas
celle qui rentre dans le système
énergétique
si la machine se trouve chez vous et
qu'elle sert à assurer le confort
thermique
c'est là si elle sert à autre chose donc
là tourniquet tafer la vinaigrette ou la
machine à laver
c'est là où l'ascenseur si vous êtes
assez riche pour avoir un penthouse avec
ascenseur privatif
voilà c'est ici si la machine se trouve
au bureau donc un certain nombre de gens
ici qui ont la chance de travailler dans
un bureau
et bien si ça sert à éviter d'avoir
froid l'hiver éventuellement chaud l'été
c'est là et si ça sert à autre chose
c'est ici si la machine se trouve dans
une usine où elle sert à produire un
objet par exemple ça eh bien elle se
trouve dans la case industrie si la
machine sert à vous nourrir elle se
trouve là et enfin si la machine sert à
déplacer des personnes ou des
marchandises
ça se trouve là et maintenant je vais
cercle et tous ceux qui en france
provient des combustibles fossiles
je vous pose la question pensez vous que
la france soit un pays tout nucléaire
qui pense oui bon on est bien d'accord
ce qui est certain c'est que tout
nucléaire est une approximation
acceptable pour l'électricité
je dis bien c'est une approximation
acceptable 75% de l'électricité est
nucléaire en france cela étant ça ne
fait pas de nous les premiers
consommateurs d'électricité nucléaire
par personne au monde qui sont les
premiers du pied premier consommateur
d'électricité nucléaire par personne au
monde bien et suit loi suédoise sur les
premiers consommateurs d'électricité
nucléaire par personne au monde
et ils ont raison de le faire selon moi
donc vous avez ici tout ce qui vient des
combustibles fossiles donc la france
n'est pas un pays tout nucléaire et
attaquer la loi de transition
énergétique par la question nucléaire
était vraiment prendre le problème avec
une logique shadok que j'ai exposé tout
à l'heure c'est à dire s'attaquer à un
problème d'une manière qui n'allait pas
le résoudre et ne pas s'attaquer aux
vrais problèmes urgents de court terme
qui lui est en train de se matérialiser
à nos dépens juste un truc en passant le
charbon même en france s'est pas
complètement ridicule ou et ça fait à
peu près 10% de nos émissions de co2
alors où est le charbon en france un peu
dans la production électrique 3 4 % de
nos émissions de co2 un peu dans les
réseaux de chaleur un tout petit peu
dans le chauffage et chez les ouvriers
de florange qui aimerait bien qu'on
regarde donc dans la production d'acier
il n'empêche que la france comme le
monde dans son ensemble est un pays à
dominante fossiles est un pays à
dominante fossile donc vous avez ici
la répartition de l'énergie utilisée
dans le monde et vous voyez que 80% de
l'énergie mondiale vient des
combustibles fossiles alors le
dictionnaire est bien fait ce sont
vraiment des fossiles voilà votre
pétrole à ses origines ses jolis seins
depuis sympa on trouve je trouve qu'une
raffinerie enfin je pense que vous en
pensez donc c'est plus joli en
l'occurrence et du plancton et des
microalgues le plancton et les micro
algues sont des êtres vivants et vous
savez que sur terre les êtres vivants
procède de la chimie du carbone
ils sont pas encore constitués de
silicium et de titane
j'espère que ça sera pas le cas je m'en
reste donc voici le pétrole à ses
origines alors qu'est ce qui lui arrive
à ce petra ce plancton et bien ce
plancton il va mourir tombé au fond des
océans pour une petite partie l'autre va
être métabolisé très vite se mélanger
avec les sédiments sur le fond des
océans l'ensemble va être enfouis par la
tectonique des plaques sous terre ça va
vous cuir ça à petit feu mieux qu une
daube
ça va vous pyrolyse et cette matière
organique en l'absence d'oxygène
fractionner la matière en question et
vous faire des résidus solides qui vont
rester dans le sédiment et des résidus
liquides et gazeux qui vont migrer et
allait se concentrer quand vous avez de
la chance dans un réservoir de pétrole
qui ressemble à ça
voilà réservoirs de pétrole s'est pas
vraiment réservoir de votre voiture
d'avoir de pétrole c'est pas un machin
que vous remplissiez que vous vider
comme ça en très exactement quarante
cinq secondes et demie c'est une roche
poreuse plus ou moins imprégnés
d'hydrocarbures et si vous aller creuser
au bon endroit
pompey un grand coup vous en sortez de
pétrole ce processus qui a conduit mère
nature à créer le plancton à le faire
tomber au fond des océans à le faire
sédimenter et c1 a pris 300 millions
d'années
2 à un rendement de 10 - 12 mai 3 et
surtout il est gratuit le pétrole est
gratuit totalement gratuit et par un peu
gratuit il est totalement gratuit
pas une personne dans cette salle n'a
payé le moindre centime ou le moindre
oubli moindre kopeck où le moindre yens
pour que le pétrole ce cri accord au
moment où l'espèce humaine apparaît la
nature a fait le boulot pour nous tout
seuls et le pétrole est là et c'est
comme dans un supermarché sans caisse il
ya qu à prendre et servir les personnes
vous demande de payer le pétrole est
gratuit vous savez que dans les slogans
environnementalistes il est courant de
trouver le vent c'est gratuit pourquoi
est ce qu'on ne l'utiliserai pas le
soleil c'est gratuit pourquoi est-ce
qu'on utiliserait pas mais le pétrole
est gratuit c'est bien pour ça qu'on l'a
utilisé c'est bien pour ça qu'on l'a
utilisé alors ballon pétrole et gaz
ils sont formés de la même manière
même motif même punition sauf que cette
fois là ça s'est formé en gros paquet
voilà le charbon et à 300 millions
d'années exactement pareil donc des
êtres vivants avant les arbres à fleurs
et grandes fougères
ça tombe par terre la tecktonik machin
truc bidule et 300 millions d'années
plus tard les polonais sont à l'oeuvre
voilà 28 donc les combustibles fossiles
sont aussi gratuit que le vent et le
soleil aussi gratuit ce qui va nous
coûter dans les deux cas de figure c'est
d'aller chercher l'énergie là où elle
est puisque l'économie ne paye que les
hommes ce que vous payez quand vous
achetez un objet ça n'est qu'un
empilement de salaire et de rente qui
vont des ressources qui ont été créés
gratuitement à l'objet transformé ça
n'est que ça que vous payez l'argent ne
paye que des hommes
et c'est justement pour ça qu'on va
avoir un petit sujet avec les nerfs
moderne
alors imaginons que je prenne le volume
d'air dans cet amphithéâtre là j'ai pris
un cube d'air de 10 mètres de côté mais
enfin en ordre de grandeur ne doit pas
être très loin ici et maintenant je vous
le fais à 1000 mètres cubes si vous êtes
sympas je vous fais 20% des tubes
imaginons que ça souffle à 80 km heure
ce qui n'est pas le cas dans cet amphi
sinon vous auriez un peu de mal à
m'entendre c'est à dire 45 2 et non pas
55 comme je les dis pardon étourderie il
n'ya pas longtemps
et bien si vous faites passer ce volume
d'air donc celui de l'amphi à 80
km/heure ça souffle 1 45e 1
dans une éolienne à l'arrivée vous allez
récupérer le contenu énergétique de 3000
et de pétrole
le vent est gratuit le pétrole est
gratuit à votre avis qu'est-ce qui prend
le moins de travail pour récupérer
l'énergie
bah oui
pas de sortie d'une école que je ne
nommerai pas pour comprendre que c'est
évidemment le pétrole qui gagne et comme
c'est le pétrole qui gagne et qui font
moins de travail pour le pétrole
eh bien ça vous explique la différence
de coût à gauche vous avez six à huit
centimes en sortie d'éoliennes mais sauf
que quand vous êtes en sortie
d'éoliennes
vous n'avez pas fini le travail parce
que si vous comptez que en sortie
d'éoliennes ça veut dire vous prenez pas
le train quand ya pas de vent donc ça
veut dire que sur l'affiché annonçant ma
conférence vous avez jean marc jancovici
viendra le 22 novembre virgule sous
réserve qu'ils aient du vent bah oui non
par évident en l'occurrence y en avait
un peu mais je serais pas arrivé à
l'heure si vous voulez que je vienne de
toute façon enfin hors jeu chutes de
météorites ou contrôleur des impôts qui
débarque chez moi mais sinon si vous
voulez que je vienne de toute façon pas
ce que j'aurais fait une phobie
administratives et là si vous voulez que
je débarque de toute façon à ce moment
il faut avoir pris le kilowattheure
éolien quand le vent souffle et l'avoir
stockée pour être sûr de faire avancer
le train de la semaine sauf le jour où
j'ai décidé de le prendre et à ce moment
vous rajouter le coût du stockage ou le
coût du moyen que vous avez dû utiliser
quand ya pas de vente et que vous avez
dû construire aussi donc vous doubler
les capacités productives en baissant
les facteurs de charge de chacune
donc le coût complet de votre système il
est nécessairement très au dessus de 8
centimes le kilowattheure est en fait si
vous faites un rapide calcul d'ordre de
grandeur que je vous montrerai tout à
l'heure c'est pas un peu s'est
considérablement plus cher d'avoir de
l'électricité disponible à tout moment
avec une injection dans le système qui
est intermittente et fatale à droite
quand vous sortez le pétrole du puits
vous avez déjà un stock votre stock est
déjà là encore votre pétrole vous pouvez
l'utiliser quand il sort du puy vous
pouvez utiliser un mois après deux mois
après pour l'utiliser de la nuit le jour
en l'occurrence vous lasse des besoins
de leurs affidés mais c'est pas grand
chose en termes énergétiques et il est
là quand vous en avez envie
d'accord donc quand vous décidez de
monter dans votre voiture à 8 heures du
matin c'est vraiment là que la voiture
avancer l avance pas juste quand il ya
du vent
en dix ans les totaux montent il ya du
vent dépêche toi d'aller au bureau et 3
heures du matin on s'en fout ou
inversement chef je suis pas venu parce
qu'elle ait pas de vent d'accord le
litre de pétrole offre pas cet
inconvénient d'accord
donc la fonction de stock est déjà là et
vous avez le kilowattheure de pétrole en
sortie depuis pour le ridicule prix de
0,3 centime donc la physique vous dit tu
as physique pas la mauvaise volonté des
politiques s'en fout de la mauvaise
volonté des politiques ils peuvent rien
contre la physique la physique vous dit
que entre à gauche et à droite
vous avez de manière absolument
irrémédiable un facteur de quelques
dizaines en termes de prix à l'arrivée
et c'est irrémédiable et si vous ne
payez pas en prise directe vous le
paierez en prix en direct via des taxes
des subventions etc
on s'en fout le canal par lequel vous le
payez c'est juste pas le sujet donc si
on en paye moins à gauche on en paiera
plus à droite juste
encore une fois on additionne de
l'action humaine pour arriver au
résultat ça peut passer par plein de ce
comme internet ça peut passer par plein
de chemin donc le et je le répète
historiquement on est passé de la gauche
à la droite
et quand nos ancêtres ont fait ça il ya
deux siècles on ne sachant pas ce
qu'était le changement climatique
sauf quelques-uns et en ne sachant pas
ce que c'était que le pic de production
sauf quelques-uns
ils l'ont fait pour une raison physique
parfaitement valable qui est que ces
achement plus facile d'utiliser à droite
que la gauche
donc c'est ce qu'on a fait et
aujourd'hui penser qu'on va faire
rentrer de génie dans la boîte en
gardant le niveau d'approvisionnement
énergétique qu'on a aujourd'hui
juste avec la gauche je le répète je
parie tout mon argent avec qui veut dans
cette salle 300 fois s'il le faut que
c'est juste totalement impossible donc
un monde 100 % le vénère est possible
mais votre pouvoir d'achat sera divisé
par la cie c'est la volonté de la
démocratie moi ça me dérange parfois me
traîner dans un magasin de fringues pour
m'acheter des vestes je supporte très
bien les chaussettes et les six trous et
donc je il ya aucun problème mais le
c'est bien ça qu'on achète un il faut
comprendre que c'est bien ça qu'on
achète pour avant de continuer je vais
fait je vais faire un court intermède
publicitaire pour les lieux c'est à dire
je vais me rappeler une petite oie
physique vous vous rappelez quand
physique il ya une loi très désagréable
que
même moi je suis encore capable de me
rappeler tellement les simples qui
s'appelle la loi de conservation
donc la loi de conservation on dit une
chose de simplicime c'est que dans un
système clos l'énergie se conserve c'est
simple moi j'aime bien les voix simple
dit autrement ça veut dire que si je
prends l'humanité et que je l' empêche
de communiquer avec l'extérieur et bien
l'humanité ne peut pas faire apparaître
en son sein de l'énergie qui lui
permettrait d'exploiter les machines
d'accord des règles heureusement
impossible il ya que dans harry potter
que c'est possible mais là non ça veut
dire que si l'humanité entend pouvoir
exploiter des machines elle est obligée
d'aller trouver dans l'environnement une
énergie qui existe déjà à les obliger à
corps pas le choix
l'énergie qu'on va trouver dans
l'environnement ça s'appelle une énergie
primaire je rappelle que l'électricité
et l'hydrogène ne sont pas des énergies
primaires donc penser qu'on va résoudre
un problème d'énergie primaire avec de
l'électricité et de l'hydrogène c'est
juste impossible
enfin on peut le penser mais c'est une
connerie alors si je vois arriver ça sur
une copie alors faut que je vous fasse
quand même la blague je suis pas sûr
qu'il ait passé lui-même le concours
parce que quand un petit doute mais il
ya un élève des mines la dernière
session d'examens qui va quand même
expliqué que l'émission de gaz à effet
de serre dans l'atmosphère créé un
surplus qui réussissait à s'échapper par
le trou dans la couche d'ozone
alors il va quand même falloir qu'il m'a
dit que son fournisseur d'ecstasy
celui-là bref donc pour ceux d'entre
vous qui n'adhèrent pas à ce genre de
conclusion je rappelle encore une fois
que l'électricité et l'hydrogène ne sont
pas des énergies primaires ne sont pas
disponibles tels que dans
l'environnement donc faut les faire avec
autre chose
si vous faites de l'hydrogène
aujourd'hui en craquant du méthane ce
qui est le mode de production standard
de l'hydrogène qu'on fait en grande
quantité parce que c'est là mon de la
chimie des ongrais 1
c'est là mon de la chimie de l'ammoniac
donc de la chimie des engrais on sait
très bien faire ça en craquant du
méthane et ça fait autant de co2 que
vous voulez donc aujourd'hui la voiture
à hydrogène même pareil que la voiture
électrique en chine c'est possible ça
vous crache plein de co2 la pose aucun
problème je le répète toutes les
énergies primaires sont gratuites
la seule chose qui coûte c'est d'aller
les chercher et donc de manière
irrémédiable les énergies diffuse et non
pilotable seront plus chers que
énergie concentrée stockables de manière
irrémédiable
donc s'il ya dans cet amphi des gens qui
font des recherches sur l'amélioration
du solaire c'est très bien pour quelques
applications de niche ça ne résoudra pas
le problème que je vais vous évoquez
maintenant ça ne résoudra pas le
problème que je vais vous évoquez
maintenant vient du fait que on a une
représentation erronée donc à nouveau la
logique shadok s'est invité dans la
sphère de notre système productif
un certain nombre d'entre vous ont suivi
des cours d'économie à l'école qui a
suivi des cours d'économie à l'école
dans le salle a pas beaucoup donc ça va
vous êtes pas trompés averti vous savez
que dans la vision académique de
l'économie vous avez deux facteurs de
production dans l'économie le capital et
le travail
donc vous avez des gens qui investissent
vous avez lisez les échos que je lis
tous les jours des gens qui investissent
les gens qui travaillent et crack
vous avez de la production d'accord
c'est comme ça que ça marche
si la production n'est pas assez élevé à
ce moment tout un tas de gens rouspètent
en disant baisser le coût du travail
comme ça ces feignants de chômeurs se
lèveront le matin au lieu de rien [ __ ]
aux frais de la collectivité et ont dit
à la banque centrale
arrosez les banques de liquidités comme
ça elles prêteront aux vrais projets et
on pourra avoir des investissements à
peu près tout genre de truc qu'on entend
en ce moment or je vais vous montrer
tout à l'heure que depuis 2007
c'est le genre de remettre qu'on essaye
d'appliquer à l'économie occidentale et
comme disait ma fille quand elle avait
deux ans pourtant ça mieux pas
s'améliore pas alors ça s'améliore pas
pour une raison simple c'est que tous
les atomes qui sont contenus dans les
objets que vous avez là vous avez besoin
de les retrouver à gauche il se crée pas
en cours de route dont vous avez aussi
besoin dans notre système productif de
ressources à transformer pour faire les
objets qu'on va produire et d'une
capacité de transformation qui n'est
rien d'autre que le travail tous les
objets que vous avez dans cette salle
sans aucune exception vos vêtements
ce sur quoi vous êtes assis les marches
que vous avez monté ce qu'on mangera
tout à l'heure ils seront boira surtout
pour oublier tout ça les moyens de
transport qui vous ont permis de
venir ici les lunettes pour ceux qui
comme moi sont trop vieux ou ceux qui
n'ont pas de chance et qui voit pas bien
les gens tout ça ça n'est rien d'autre
que des ressources naturelles transformé
par notre activité donc mère nature nous
fournit le tableau de mendeleïev qui va
jusqu'à 92 92
je voulais suisse plus de quoi les
transformer et voici les fourchettes les
couteaux les panières fond et tout ce
qui a suivi pas de ressources pas de
production et la capacité de
transformation
et bien c'est mon énergie et si je dis
que la carcasse humaine comme pour un
dans cette histoire le parc de machines
que nous avons désormais à notre
disposition compte pour 200 en moyenne
mondiale
bah oui c'est mon rapport de 1 à 200
tout à l'heure donc la capacité de
transformation des ressources elle est
assurée pour 200 par les machines et
pour un par les hommes ce qui est une
autre manière de dire qu'aujourd'hui le
pib est dépendant au premier ordre de la
quantité de machines qui travaillent et
pas de la quantité de gens qui
travaillent et si vous êtes limité en
énergie dans un pays donné et donc
limité en quantité de machines qui
travaillent si vous augmentez la
population vous augmentez les chômeurs
c'est tout est ce que c'est ce qui est
en train de se passer en france en ce
moment la france est en stress
énergétique comme toute l'europe
le seul pays qui va bien c'est
l'allemagne parce qu'il est en déclin
démographique plus d'enfants plus de
chômeurs
c'est très simple ça renverse un peu le
raisonnement c'est un peu désagréable
mais bon le capital dans cette histoire
derrière d'autre qu'une boucle internes
au système donc prenons cet immeuble qui
est un élément capital c'est un truc qui
durent plus longtemps que leurs pendants
lequel laquelle on va s'en servir
ou prenons un brevet elle qui est un
truc qui dure de ça n'est rien d'autre
qu'une boucle interne du système
il a fallu pour produire cet élément de
capital des ressources et de l'énergie
comme les autres pour faire cet immeuble
il faut des ressources et de l'énergie
et même pareil juste ça va durer un peu
plus longtemps que le reste admettons
maintenant donc mon système dépend il a
quatre intrants non-système
effectivement des ressources de la
capacité transformation des machines de
la capacité de transformation et de
pilotage parce qu'on a aussi une
cervelle même si ces 2 % du poids
1.5 et les autres donc on peut un peu
piloter le système est
après le max de la production va être le
max du premier facteur limitant une bête
optimisation sous contrainte un bon eh
bien aujourd'hui dans les sociétés
industrielles ce je vais vous montrer
c'est que le premier facteur limitant
c'est devenu l'énergie et si vous avez
l'énergie qui vient à être compressé la
production sera compressé quelles que
soient les promesses de campagne de
n'importe quel candidat qui viendra
faire des grands moulinets sur les
plateaux de télé c'est indépendant de sa
volonté à bref délai parce que les
éléments structurels du système ou une
inertie qui se mesure en siècle face à
la volonté de quelqu'un dont la capacité
d'action se mesure en année voit en moi
quand on est dans une société cotée non
pardon je suis désagréable eh bien vous
avez je veux dire la volonté de
l'individu qui pilote c'est pas le
déterminant du premier rang au bacon
terme
absolument pas si vous avez un stress
sur les ressources
prenez l'exemple de la pêche vous aurez
un stress sur la production aussi je
vous signale en passant que le pic
mondial des captures en mer c'est 95
ça fait 20 ans qu'on l'a passé et que
les captures en mer baisse est en train
de surexploiter à peu près la totalité
de ce qui existe alors la poêle à la
conséquence de ce que je viens de vous
raconter et non pas la preuve
mais la conséquence c'est ce qui va
suivre la première conséquence c'est que
tant que les hommes n'ont que leurs bras
et aux jambes et bien la croissance du
pib c'est la croissance de la population
et quand vous n'avez pas de croissance
de population ce qui est grosso modo le
cas entre le début de l' empire romain
et le milieu du moyen-âge et bien je
n'ai pas de croissance du pib jusqu'au
début de la révolution industrielle
vous en avez quasiment pas en fait il y
en a un peu quand même il ya des moulins
bref mais enfin comparé à ce qui va
suivre ses cacahuètes
harry les combustibles fossiles et hop
c'est parti pour l'expérience yale alors
vous savez peut-être que on prête à un
économiste qui s'appelle boulder cette
blague qui est si vous croisez quelqu'un
qui vous promet la croissance
perpétuelle c'est un fou un économiste
bien évidemment l'exponentielle va pas
durer sur ce monde finit bien évidemment
le sol macroéconomistes digne de ce nom
que je connaisse s'appelle de l'iss
meadows il a fait dans les années 60 de
la dynamique des systèmes web haïti est
publié avec sa femme hélas décédé depuis
donné le la un livre retentissant au
début des années soixante dix pendant 70
qui s'intitulait de limitrophes en
anglais et en français ça a été très mal
traduit sur halte à la croissance
complètement stupide et vous en fait si
la vulgarisation de son approche par la
dynamique des systèmes dans lesquels ils
avaient couple et les flux économiques
avec les flux physiques sous jacents et
meadows était arrivé à une conclusion
très simple il avait dit encore cherche
la croissance perpétuelle le système
s'effondre sur lui même par défaut de
ressources ou défaut d'environnement
dans le courant du 21e siècle
donc bienvenue dans le monde on y est ça
commence par petits bouts
pour le moment on est encore je le dis
dans la phase globalement ascendante
alors autre caractéristique
enfin autre concrétisation de ce que je
viens de vous raconter vous avez ici un
nuage de points enfin c'est le nuage qui
est une droite en l'occurrence qui part
de 1965 en bas à gauche qui se termine
en 2015 en haut à droite et année après
année donc ça suit l'ordre chronologique
en suivant la ligne j'ai mis sur l'axé
horizontal la quantité d'énergie
consommée par le parc de machines
mondial donc les hommes enfin le parc de
machines mondiale et en ordonnée le pib
mondial en monnaie constante et bien
vous voyez oublier aux études d'économie
le meilleur modèle macroéconomique au
monde c'est une droite
j'ai pas besoin de fonction d'utilité
dont j'ai jamais compris à quoi il
servait soit dit en passant
parce que j'avais su 6 a cédé 0,3 utile
ou 1,2 utile
donc il n'y a pas besoin de ce genre de
trucs qui servent à rien vous avez une
droite et vous allez ça marche très bien
vous verrez que ça marche dans les deux
sens alors ça marche en valeur absolue
et ça marche également variations vous
avez ici deux courbes en verre et je le
répète ses courbes sont la conséquence
logique de mon rapport demain à 200 ce
n'est pas la preuve c'est la conséquence
logique
vous avez ici envers la variation de
l'approvisionnement énergétique annuelle
dans le monde
donc la variation en gros du parc de
machines qui fonctionnent ça revient à
ça et en bleu
la variation du pib mondial pas vous
voyez j'ai l'un et l'autre j'ai l'autre
géant et ça explique pourquoi quand vous
regardez l'approvisionnement énergétique
dans une zone
ça vous donne en première approximation
la manière dont va évoluer le pib et
c'est ce qui me permet de dire ce que je
vais vous montrer dans pas longtemps que
je peux vous annoncer qu'il va y avoir
une nouvelle marche d'escalier dans
l'économie mondiale dans les deux ans
qui viennent y avoir une je ne sais pas
d'où elle viendra j'ai aucune idée de
est-ce qu'il va s'agir d'une crise
monétaire en chine d'une nouvelle crise
des emprunts immobiliers aux états unis
du défaut de l'espagne dopée foutrement
aucune idée par contre la probabilité
qu'il n'arrive rien dans les deux ans
qui viennent
compte tenu du fait que
l'approvisionnement énergétique mondial
est en train de stagner et le pétrole en
train de baisser
me paraît assez faible donc le prochain
président élu
attendez vous à ce que il se coltine une
crise carabinée est jugé le haut essayer
de choisir à l'aune de ça je sais très
bien qu une élection c'est une
élimination et comprend le moins mauvais
n'est pas le meilleur
enfin essayez quand même d'avoir ça en
tête bah oui vous savez si toutes les
copies ont entre 0 et 5 et en premier
quand même c'est pas le premier de votre
coeur mais il existe quand même et si
vous choisissez pas vous vous laissez
les autres choisir bien comprendre ça
alors je reprends la suite de cette
petite digression quantitative lavaud
jour vous osez reproduit à nouveau
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne entre le début de cette série
statistique et les chocs pétroliers
cet approvisionnement augmente de 2,5
pour cent par an
donc je reprends la preuve
hautement énergétiques par personne et
vous voyez plus 2,5 pour cent par an
jusqu'au choc pétrolier qu'est ce que ça
veut dire cette histoire ça veut dire
que chaque année vous avez 2,5 pour cent
de machines en plus par terriens pour
produire 2,5 pour cent des machines on
travaille jusque si elles sont pas au
travail le concept d'énergie
c'est donc une manière de dire que
chaque terrien est capable de
transformer chaque année 2,5 pour cent
de ressources en plus que l'année
précédente et donc mesuré au sens du pib
puisque la production mesure des
transformations le pib mesure des
transformations une valeur ajoutée c'est
une transformation
ça veut dire que la production par
personne toutes choses égales par
ailleurs augmentent de moins de 0 5% là
dessus il faut rajouter le g10 des
chercheurs et des ingénieurs présents
dans cette salle qui fait que c'est pas
plus 2,5 c'est un peu mieux que ça c'est
plutôt plus trois verrières plus un peu
plus tard mais c'est pas sur la base de
zéro en énergie qu'on arrive à faire + 5
par personne
c'est vraiment l'augmentation du parc de
machines par personne qui est le premier
driver le premier déterminant de la
hausse de la production par personne et
puis à partir des chocs pétroliers
vous voyez que mme ida se fatigue un peu
d'accord il alla - un peu - doré
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne en fait il ya deux ans là
dedans je vais finir derrière augmente
en moyenne d'une fraction de points par
an ça ça veut dire que la production par
personne elle descend d'un ordre de
grandeur en terme de hausse annuelle
par contre le résidu d'efficacité
énergétique lui reste à peu près le même
et dans les pays de l' ocde
nous prenons de la vence nous sommes à 0
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne dans les pays de l' ocde
n'augmente plus depuis les chocs
pétroliers alors très souvent on a
tendance à penser que les chocs
pétroliers ont caractérisé une variation
de prix sur le pétrole
ça monte giscard dit à la télé quand
même faudrait s'en occuper le prix
redescend fin du problème
en fait non les chocs pétroliers c'est
le début de nos problèmes c'est le
moment où la dérive et sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne en occident devient nul et
c'est à ce moment là que pour préserver
un système de redistribution qui avaient
été calés sur une production par
personne qu'ils augmentaient de plus de
3% par an on commence à andé
et tous les démocraties pour préserver
ça parce que l'électeur si vous lui
dites la redistribution je te la fais
variés comme les recettes comme dans une
entreprise en une entreprise détient
moins de chiffre d'affaires janvier
rouge baisser les salaires
c'est très simple même moi j'ai eu à le
faire malheureusement un moment donc on
s'adapte c'est pas drôle mais on sait le
faire
sauf que en démocratie vous vous adaptez
pas vous n'allez pas vous faire élire
sur le fait que vous allez baisser les
revenus des gens dont vous voulez
maintenant donc il faut bien trouver le
pognon quelque part donc on s'embête
alors la dette c'est votre assurance-vie
lien pour ceux d'entre vous qui savent
pas c'est l'épargné donc la dette pas
rembourser un jour c'est votre assurance
vie qui disparaît voilà et j'ai une
bonne nouvelle pour les vieux ça va
arriver c'est si je prend à nouveau tous
les paris avec qui veut ça va arriver
d'une manière ou d'une autre je ne sais
pas si ça aura gras dans 1 ans d'ordis
soudan 15 à mon avis dans beaucoup moins
dix le dans les cdo on passe à 0 c'est
ça les chocs pétroliers ce qui veut dire
que dans l' ocde la productivité du
travail s'arrête de croître rapidement à
partir des chocs pétroliers
non pas parce que les services s'est pas
productif et c'est juste pour des
raisons physiques et en fait la raison
pour laquelle on a développé des
services depuis les chocs pétroliers
c'est l'exact inverse
on a cherché à tirer le meilleur parti
des flux physiques existants et donc on
a rempilé sur des flux physiques
existants de plus en plus d'emplois
possibles qui en dépendaient le long
d'une chaîne plus longue donc
l'accroissement des services c'est pas
ce qui a causé le gain d'efficacité
énergétique
c'est la réponse à la baisse de la
croissance de l'approvisionnement
énergétique
sinon on aurait continué à faire de plus
en plus de biens et des maisons plus en
plus grande et on serait passé de 25 à
40 mètres carrés et puis de 40 à 100
mètres carrés par personne et vous
auriez tous une salle de sport et un
jacuzzi chez vous exactement ce qu'on
aurait fait et vous auriez tous une
navette spatiale pour les faire le tour
du soleil pour vingt ans que c'est quand
même rigolo
voilà ce qu'on aurait fait s'il y avait
eu la croissance de l'approvisionnement
énergétique par personne qui avait
continué à gagner de gainey de gains
et le fait qu'on soit passé à une
économie de services c'est parce que
justement c'est plus possible en 2005
en fait il s'est passé quelque chose que
vous voyez un tout petit peu sur cette
courbe là mais je vais vous le détailler
vous voyez que non seulement ça s'arrête
doxa croit plus mais ça paie ce voile à
l'approvisionnement mondial en pétrole
selon les statistiques mensuelles de
l'énergie information agency alors quand
vous regardez les statistiques de bp ce
qu'on vous donne c'est la courbe duo
s'est tous les liquides dans les
liquides vous avez les agrocarburants
vous avez des liquides de gascon rien à
faire là parce que les liquides de gaz
pour ceux d'entre vous qui sont pas
fâchés avec la chimie c'est les chaînes
carbonées c2a c4 c'est et anne butane
propane et on appelle ça liquides de gaz
parce qu on les sépare par liquéfaction
dans les usines de traitement du gaz
quand on extrait le gaz des gisements et
parce que dans les gisements n'y a pas
que du méthane
il ya aussi des molécules un peu plus
lourde et la séparation du méthane parce
que dans les réseaux de gaz on ne laisse
que du méthane
il ya des spécifications gars clair avec
les autres gaz se fait en condensant les
autres gaz et donc on a coutume de les
appeler des liquides de gaz
sauf que c'est pas liquidé que ça fait
pas des carburants si vous enlevez les
liquides de gaz vous vous retrouvez avec
la courbe du bas et vous voyez qu'à
partir de 2005 elle augmentait jusqu'en
2005 vous avez un long long long plateau
là ça remonte un peu mais c'est
largement dû à un truc qui n'est pas non
plus du pétrole qui s'appelle des
condenseurs a qui sont des molécules un
peu plus lourde que les liquides de gaz
n'est toujours pas du pétrole le vrai
pétrole en fait depuis 2005 il
n'augmente quasiment plus mais s'il
n'augmente quasiment plus dans un monde
où les producteurs gardent une fraction
croissante pour leur propre population
et où les chinois se mettent à s'équiper
en bagnole l'arithmétique et en reine
ça en fait de moins en moins pour les
classes moyennes inférieures de
l'occident et vous avez ici
l'approvisionnement en pétrole dans la
zone ocde dans en europe pardon mais
dans la zone ocde c'est pareil et vous
voyez que le pétrole passe par un
maximum secondaire mais qui vont absolue
était là mais beaucoup plus
régulièrement en 2006 et que depuis sa
les clean c'est la raison et le pétrole
est la première énergie consommée dans
la zone en europe comme dans la zone
ocde
alors non regardez bien ce qui se passe
et nrj paris nrj en fait quand je prends
l'europe le charbon décline sur les 50
dernières années parce que la production
européenne de charbon est passé par un
maximum 85 et que le charbon ne
s'importe pas si facilement que ça vous
n'avez que 15% du charbon mondiale qui
passe une frontière entre production et
consommation parce que c'est lourd c'est
pondéreux c'est compliqué à transporter
vous mettez pas un terminal charbonnier
comme ça du jour au lendemain au port du
havre
ça vous demande une logistique portuaire
et surtout dans l'hinterland qui est
absolument monstrueuse
il faut des trains etc donc ça décline
en plus ça fait plein de co2 donc c'est
très bien
le pétrole décline en occident depuis
2005 ce n'est pas un hasard c'est depuis
le moment où la hausse de la production
mondiale a quasiment cessé le gaz
décline en europe depuis 2005 parce que
la mer du nord a passé son pic de
production en 2005 et que contrairement
à une idée couramment répandue en france
le gaz c'est pas juste la russie en
europe c'est 60% la mer du nord la
russie c'est 20 % de gaz à 60%
est ce qu'on apporte en valeur absolue
en quantité en valeur absolue de russie
c'est stable d'accord donc si vous avez
un socle européen qui décliné une
importation stable par dessus dans
l'ensemble des clients
le nucléaire décline parce qu on en a la
trouille du coup l'ensemble de
l'approvisionnement européen est passé
par un maximum en 2006 avec ce que je
vous ai expliqué juste avant ça veut
dire que depuis 2006 il ya de moins en
moins de machines au travail en europe
donc on produit de moins en moins et
donc on consomme de moins en moins ou
alors on consomme toujours pareil on
s'embête haye d'aurore
et en fait quand vous regardez
l'évolution lente non pas de la quantité
mais de sa variation vous vous rendez
compte que c'est pas une surprise qu'on
soit passé par un maximum en 2006 ça
pouvait se prédire presque vous avez ici
la variation de l'approvisionnement
énergétique européen donc là vous avez
l'approvisionnement lui-même
et là vous avez sa variation annuelle de
combien de % ils varient d'une année sur
l'autre
est ce que vous voyez c'était que dans
les années 60 s'accroissaient de 4% par
an puis 2-3 les chocs pétroliers sont
des accidents sur une tendance qui
régulière puis 2 2 puis 2 1 puis 2 0
puis 2 - quelque chose et ça va
continuer et ça va continuer alors cette
inversion de la dérive et a provoqué une
inversion de la production industrielle
vous avez ici exactement comme je
voulais montrer pour le pib
là je vous montre pour la zone ocde
l'énergie consommée dans la zone
quel que soit l'usagé et en ordonnée la
production industrielle de la zone est
bien avouer que le max de production
industrielle s'est 2007 et qu'on n'a pas
retrouvé le niveau de 2007 dans la zone
ocde
donc il ya vraiment un maximum
historique à la production industrielle
en 2007 et depuis ça fait le chemin
inverse la production diminue parce que
l'énergie diminuent on n'a jamais d
industrialiser ni la france ni l'europe
ni l' ocde entre 73 et 2007 ça c'est des
foutaises
on fait moins de chaussettes et plus
d'airbus mais la production industrielle
globale a augmenté elle augmente jusqu
en 2007 y compris en france y compris en
europe
elle augmente pas avec de plus en plus
d'emplois mais ça c'est un autre sujet
mais en termes d'objets et de valeur des
objets produits
ça augmente et le rhum regardez
maintenant quelques pays bien
particulier voici la grèce alors c'est
toujours le même graphique l'énergie
disponible en grèce le pib grec
alors oui ça monte ça monte ça monte ça
monte ça monte ça monte et la raison
c'est que c'était le pays européens en
2006 qui était le plus dépendant du
pétrole qui est s'est retrouvé entre
l'énergie la plus contrainte après 2006
donc c'est le contraire un volet le plus
vite regardez l'italie pareil ils ont
quasiment 50% de leur mix qui est du
pétrole en 2006 et ils ont fait boum
le chemin je descends l'énergie donc je
descends le pib voilà
ce par anja c'est pareil 50% de pétrole
dans le mix en 2006 c'est 2006 et pouf
la courbe qui s'inverse
on va à un moment ou à un autre tout
suivre le même chemin je répète
certains dans cette salle vont me dire
il raconte n'importe quoi si on manquait
d'énergie on devrait le voir dans le
prix je suis donc dit tiens je vais
faire un test idiot je vais regarder
comment avariée historiquement le prix
du pétrole en fonction de la quantité
qu'on consomme
je veux bien finir par retrouver
l'élasticité de mes cours d'économie
deux jeunes hommes cette courbe uden en
abscisse la quantité de pétrole consommé
dans le monde et en ordonnée le prix du
baril en dollars constants évidemment
s'il y avait une élasticité prix volume
je devrais avoir un nuage de points
ordonné le long d'un truc comme ça plus
y en a moins c'est cher moyen n'a plus
c'est cher d'être d'accord pour être une
droite
un machin concaves ou convexes m'en fous
enfin c'est comme ça en fait non si vous
voulez théorisé ça en première
approximation c'est beaucoup plus drôle
que sa robe pouvait dire il ya deux
régimes inélastique il ya un régime
inélastique avec un prix fixe et un
volume qui fait n'importe quoi
un deuxième régime inélastique avec un
volume prescrits et un prix qui fait
n'importe quoi de nouveau un régime
quasi inélastique avec le volume qui
varie beaucoup alors que le prix varie
pas et un dernier âge etc
voilà donc il n'y a strictement aucun
lien entre la quantité de pétrole
disponible et le prix du pétrole à long
terme 0 il y en a à très court terme
donc si demain matin je supprime à plein
de production pétrolière dans le monde
la à très court terme je vais voir le
prix du pétrole augmente et mais c'est à
très court terme
derrière le manque de pétrole va casser
l'économie physiquement et le prix
deviendra exactement ce qu'il a envie de
devenir
donc en fait la hausse du prix du
pétrole je n'ai pas la voir à travers le
prix du baril je vais la voir à travers
l'augmentation des chômeurs la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat et des trucs comme ça je
ne vais pas la voir à travers une
variation de prix nominal sur le marché
je vous le redis autrement la variation
de prix nominal sur le marché
et vous donne aucune indication sur la
disponibilité réelle de la ressource
aucune c'est désagréable pour les
économistes libéraux de dire sa vérité
et c'est la raison pour laquelle quand
les yeux fait des prévisions de prix du
pétrole ça ressemble à ça donc en bleu
vous avez ce qui a vraiment été le prix
du pétrole est là vous avez les
projections de prix du pétrole fait dans
les world energy outlook successifs bon
je peux vous dire que si chez moi j'ai
un responsable marketing qui fait des
prévisions de ventes de cette manière je
peux le garder longtemps donc le les
yeux quand elle donne un prix pour le
pétrole
elle donne un prix pour le pétrole et
puis sujets suivants on s'en fout
complètement de ce qu'elle raconte
aucune espèce d'importance le prix du
pétrole et ska qui sera ce qui sera par
contre la production de pétrole
elle laissera pas ce qu'elle sera il est
possible d'avoir un avis sur ce que sera
la production de pétrole
donc je reprends pour finir cette partie
économique
la courbe que je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure donc je vous dis il ya le
premier choc pétrolier qui arrête la
hausse
en fait vous avez un deuxième arrêt de
la hausse en 2005 2006 2007 au moment où
la production mondiale de pétrole
s'arrête de croître et alors maintenant
regarder comment a évolué le pib par
personne dans un certain nombre de zones
je commence par prendre le monde dans
son ensemble + 3 % par an et quelque
avant les chocs pétroliers et ça descend
juste à 0 5%
pendant plus deux pour cent et quelques
à 0 5% par an après les chocs pétroliers
et après le mini choc on va dire de 2005
ça descend encore d'un cran si je prends
en europe
vous voyez pardon j'ai les chocs
pétroliers qui marque l'arrêt de la
hausse et 2005 qui marque le début de la
baisse et alors là vous avez les trente
glorieuses pardon des trente glorieuses
les trente piteuses et dernièrement
depuis la baisse de l'énergie on est à 0
et bonnes pâques site pourquoi boom
réussite parce que dans un continent sur
un continent où vous avez les personnes
et les marchandises qui circulent
librement
si votre situation de départ c'est que
vous avez un écart de revenus de 1 à 10
entre les anglais et les polonais et que
le pib global de la zone n'augmente pas
la seule manière de rééquilibrer les
revenus par personne du polonais
l'anglais c'est d'envoyer les polonais
en grande-bretagne d'envoyer les usines
anglaises en pologne
et ça ça rééquilibre les revenus sauf
que les anglais on dit ouais mais sauf
que ça ça nous plaît pas moi qui tu sais
que le début dans une europe où on va
garder la liberté de faire l'économie
que les acteurs microéconomique veulent
faire dans un continent en contraction
du pib
ça n'est que le début je répète ça n'est
que le début
prenons les états unis si j'étais taquin
je vous aurais masquer les abscisses et
je vous aurais demandé de quand date le
début du gaz et du pétrole de schiste
sur l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne aux états unis
alors en fait je vais être très taquin
il date de deuxième trait c'est marrant
quand même non strictement rien changé à
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne aux états unis
ça a un peu changé les importations
énergétiques des états unis alors
envoyées jusqu'au premier choc pétrolier
s'accroît fortement etc et même motif
même punition même sans compter que le
résidu de pib par personne
enfin de croissance du pib par personne
que vous avez aux états unis est un
artefact comptable c'est lié au fait que
la monstrueuse le monstrueux des
versements de liquidités sur l'économie
américaine a engendré une inflation des
actifs absolument considérable et
l'inflation des actifs quand on calcule
le pib fait du pib vrai entre guillemets
sans correction il ya plein de mécanisme
par lequel vous savez quand on calcule
le pib ont des flat les biens courants
donc c'est une paire de chaussures coûte
20% plus cher d'une année sur l'autre et
de l'inflation
et bien si un mètre carré que vous
achetez à bouygues immobilier vos 20 %
plus cher d'une année sur l'autre c'est
pas de ma passion c'est la hausse du pib
or quand vous rendez le crédit plus
facile ça fait monter les prix
donc voilà typiquement un exemple dans
lequel le fait de faire de créer des
liquidités vous fait monter le pib alors
qu'il ya plus de mètres carrés donc le
laos résiduelle du pib que vous avez aux
états unis depuis 2007 c'est ça c'est le
fait que la dette fédérale est passé de
50 à 100 % du pib en six ans je peux
vous dire que nous on est des nains de
jardin à côté
et ça a créé une inflation sur actifs
absolument considérable qui a permis aux
riches d'être encore plus riches c'est
pas rester de moyenne au pib par
personne d'augmenter mais c'était un
effet de moyenne faut quand même savoir
qu'aujourd'hui vous avez 4 % de la
population américaine qui a un emploi en
moins que en 2007 en 2007 67 % des
adultes âgés de plus de 15 ans avaient
un emploi aux etats unis aujourd'hui
c'est 62 63
donc quand on dit ils ont résolu leur
preuve de chômage je t'en fous c'est
juste que les gens n'ont pas de boulot
on va arrêter de dire qu'il n'avait pas
de boulot et vous savez que dans les
statistiques du chômage c'est les gens
qui disent qu'il veut un boulot qui
compte ceux qui disent rien et qu'on pas
de boulot et compte pas voilà voilà la
variation de l'approvisionnement
énergétique dans la zone ocde depuis 50
ans voilà la variation du pib par
personne dans la zone ocde depuis 50 ans
et vous voyez nous approchons de la zone
rouge où il va se passer des trucs
bizarroïde et à cause de la baisse du
pétrole qui est en train de se produire
en ce moment je pense qu'un événement
bizarroïde va se produire dans les moins
de 2 ans mais c'est que le début c'est
que le début au sens où nous allons
devoir transitionner pour décarbonés
l'économie ce dont je vais vous parler
maintenant en récession et non pas en
croissance
nous allons devoir décarbonés en
récession j'insiste en récession donc la
croissance verte
j'y crois pas une seconde n'existe pas
la croissance verte
ce qu'on va avoir c'est une décroissance
de toute façon il tient qu'à nous
qu'elle soit plus ou moins sympathiques
et plus ou moins gérable mais ça va
vraiment être ça le sujet alors je vais
vous parler un tout petit peu d'effet de
serre est ce assez d'économies
dématérialisés comme vous le savez
puisque plus vous allez vers la droite
et plus c'est cher donc moi y'a de
tissus plus c'est cher
génial eux c'est bien la preuve que
c'est possible
vous avez ici une je vous donnais une
petite illustration de ce qui est en jeu
quand on parle de changement climatique
je vous passe les modèles les machins
les trucs les bidules vous avez des tas
de vidéos sur internet dont les bienne
qui vous expliqueront ça très bien
je vais aller directement à la
conclusion qu'ils aient de quoi est ce
qu'on parle quand on parle de quelques
degrés variations vous avez ici l'europe
actuelle pour autant qu'on ne supprime
pas les écosystèmes installé pour faire
des champs pour se nourrir des routes
pour se déplacer des universités pour
propre pays pour propager le savoir
dons et autres babioles
aéroportuaire outre vous voyez que les
écosystèmes installés en europe sont
essentiellement des forêts ce qui veut
dire que les conditions climatiques sont
en particulier suffisamment humide pour
qu'ils poussent des grosses choses c'est
l'humidité qui est le facteur limitant
souvent voici l'europe il ya un milan
alors l'europe ya vingt mille ans est en
herbe glaciaire comme vous le savez
c'est froid il fait froid et du coup ça
ressemble pas exactement à l'europe
moderne
la première chose c'est que il n'y
aurait pas de suédois en erasmus ici car
il n'y a pas de suédois il n'y aurait
pas non plus deux finlandais ni de
danois ni d'allemands du nord en erasmus
est pas plus d'erasmus des français là
haut ils sont tous sous la glace il ya
pas plus de québécois à cette époque là
le canada est aussi sous la glace
et alors vous voyez que les écossais ne
peuvent pas mesurer deux ne veut pas
pardon menacé de faire sécession
ils sont pas là nous emmerde pas les
irlandais on peut aller jouer avec eux
au rugby et les battre les bonnes années
sans prendre le tunnel sous la manche
n'y a pas besoin de tunnel sous la
manche le trait de côte
passe à l'extérieur de la grande
bretagne actuelle parce que l'océan et
plus bas de 120 mètres alors prix les
plus bas de 120 m parce que pour faire
ces grosses carottes de glace qui sont
posées sur le nord de l'europe et le
canada font bien prendre look et par
lots vous l'avez prise dans l'océan qui
le seul gros réservoir d'eau compter sur
terre sauf que le fond de la baignoire a
pas changé toujours au même endroit le
fond de la baignoire
si vous prenez de l'eau dans la
baignoire le niveau de l'eau baisse donc
le niveau de l'océan a baissé de 120
mètres et donc pour les gens qui aiment
bien aller planquer leurs économies
crocs dans les îles anglo-normandes
c'est pas possible c'est devenu des
collines l'île de man aussi voilà les ce
qui est bien à faire de la voile en
revanche c'est pas possible non plus don
il ya plus qu la méditerranée
à la grande satisfaction de ceux qui
aiment la chaleur il fait beaucoup plus
froid donc il fait beaucoup plus sec il
ya moins d'évaporation
du coup les écosystèmes installé
ressemble à ce qu'on trouve aujourd'hui
au nord de la sibérie
c'est à peu près ça l'europe et dans ce
genre de paysage et bien on peut faire
on peut fournir à manger à un
arrondissement lyonnais un gros aux
arrondissements lyonnais 2e aller voilà
à peu près la taille de la population
humaine
à cette époque là cent mille personnes
parce que on peut pas nourrir plus
d'animaux en bout de chaîne alimentaire
dans ce genre d'écosystèmes quand
l'europe est passée du paysage de gauche
au paysage de droite
c'était lors de la dernière déglaciation
ça a pris quelques milliers d'années et
en termes de variation de la moyenne
planétaire
ça ne représente que 5 degrés de hausse
donc là vous avez l'expérience grandeur
nature qu'on a fait une fois sur les
vingt mille dernières années
qui quand qui consiste à réchauffer la
température planétaire alors on n'avait
pas les mêmes conditions initiales 2,5
degrés en quelques milliers d'années et
vous voyez le résultat
je vais maintenant un peu détaillé ce
que ça peut signifier d'aller 100 fois
plus vite
mais à ce stade je peux déjà vous donner
la conclusion ça sera la guerre partout
appliquer une hausse de température 100
fois plus rapides enfin 50 fois plus
rapide on va dire à une humanité
sédentaires de 7 milliards d'hommes
sédentaires c'est à dire qu'on se
déplace pas facilement cette époque là
on se déplacer facilement la migration
n'était pas vraiment un sujet le capital
a transporté à l'époque sur ses épaules
c'était trois pie de harpon et un pot de
peinture faisait pas de problème
la question de la décision collective
était pas vraiment un sujet le chef de
tribu avait une massue pour les grandes
occasions et ça lui permettait de régler
les problèmes de manière assez
expéditive
donc il n'y avait pas de sujet d'agilité
des populations pour bouger et
de force de frottement pour déplacer
tout un tas de trucs avec soin là si on
doit partir en emmenant sur ses épaules
l'université lyon-1 plus ligne ça parce
qu'ils sont sympas plus la ligne de
tramway plus le tunnel sous fourvière
plus les canaux plus les ports plus les
églises plus les rails plus etc
c'est plus compliqué un peu plus
compliqué et puis pour aller où ou bien
il ya personne dont il n'y a pas de
problème de gens qu'on gêne mais s'il ya
personne n'y a rien donc vous porter à
poil pas d'infrastructures rien pas de
maison de rien ou bien il ya déjà des
gens et à ce moment c'est comme nous
avec les syriens on n'est pas pressé de
voir arriver et donc sa frite donc ce
genre de déstabilisation à large échelle
mené à son terme
je vais un tout petit peu vous détailler
mais la conclusion principale absolument
évidente pour moi c'est que c'est la
guerre partout c'est absolument évident
donc quand on s'occupe des deux degrés
de l'accord de paris faut bien soupeser
oui ça va est récessif je vais vous le
montrer mais est ce que je préfère me
serrer la ceinture tout de suite ou
sombrer dans le chaos dans pas très
longtemps
ça se discute mais c'est ça les termes
du choix c'est vraiment ça les termes de
choix quelques exemples du fait que ça
attendra pas 2100 vous avez ici alors un
changement climatique comme le titre
l'indiqué ce n'est pas juste une
température qui change c'est aussi des
conditions de précipitation parce que ça
vous change le cycle de l'eau et vous
avez ici sur terre les endroits où on
s'attend à des variations significatives
du cycle de l'eau et je vais notamment
vous cercle et un premier endroit où on
s'attend à ce que sa baisse c'est le
bassin méditerranéen avec le bassin
méditerranéen va s'assécher
dans le cadre du climat qui se réchauffe
il ya un certain nombre d'autres zones
qui devrait s'assécher
regardez bien ou sur les ellipses et
maintenant je vais vous projeter une
carte non pas de l'assèchement projeté
mais de l'assèchement constatés sur les
dernières années j'ai laissé les
ellipses au même endroit et je voulais
juste montrer la carte de là où ça c'est
déjà asséchées sur les 50 dernières
années
l'effet de serre nous en voyons déjà la
traduction dans la variation du cycle de
l'eau et les syriens en ont vraiment vu
la traduction dont vous voyez ça sèche
sur le pourtour du débat
méditerranéen alors voici ici deux
courbes envers vous avez la production
céréalière en syrie et en rouge la
population syrienne
voyez jusqu'en 2007 tout va bien après
tout la malle bon parce que assad père
et fils ça fait 30 ans qu'ils se les
coltiner donc si c'est juste cinq sujets
ça aurait dû se passer différemment le
savez évidemment pas le seul déterminant
il y en a plein d'autres du reste c'est
un chapitre qui est consacré à sa d'un
bouquin je voulais montrer tout à
l'heure mais en fait beaucoup de ces
déterminants sont anciennement ou
nouvellement connecté au pétrole ou au
climat le déterminant anciens connecté
au pétrole c'est tout simplement les
frontières de la syrie
vous savez que le moyen-orient est une
création des occidentaux qui se sont
partagés le pétrole donc les plus gros
les américains ont pris plus gros paquet
l'arabie saoudite
les deuxièmes plus gros de l'époque les
anglais ont pris l'irak et les
troisièmes les français ils ont posé ce
qui reste c'est à dire la syrie on a
fait des frontières tout droite avec les
chiffres d'un côté et de l'autre on s'en
fout les sunnites d'un côté et de
l'autre ils peuvent pas se blairer mais
on s'en fout
les alaouites d'un côté de l'autre les
maronites d'un côté de l'autre les
machins les trucs les bidules tous ces
braves gens sont devenus de plus en plus
nombreux
le pétrole a commencé à devenir un
facteur de déstabilisation notamment
quand ils n'avaient plus assez ce qui
s'est passé en syrie qui a passé son pic
de production en 2002 et tous ces braves
gens quand ils se mettent à plus avoir à
manger et qu'en plus ils peuvent pas se
blairer culturellement ça commence à
faire des choses un peu explosive je le
répète c'est que le début l'algérie est
actuellement en pic de production
gazière et pétrolière ce qui lui est
mais elle a encore du pétrole et du gaz
qui lui a permis de ne pas sauter au
moment du printemps arabe au moment où
la nourriture s'est fortement renchéri
pour ses voisins tunisien et égyptien
qui avait pas de recettes à
l'exportation c'est prochain sur la
liste
donc vous avez aujourd'hui une
instabilité dans le bassin méditerranéen
parce que ces pays n'est des ressources
minières ont vu leur population croître
dans un contexte dans lequel ils vont
pas avoir la possibilité d'être
autosuffisant sur le plan agricole a par
l'agriculture on va avoir un sujet sur
les écosystèmes je vous rappelle ce que
je voulais dire en entrée si on n'a plus
d'éco système du tout eh bien il ya plus
de pays des du tout d'abord on peut
mettre le curseur entre les deux
quand on chauffe le bouillon de culture
il va se passer des choses sur les
petites bêtes
alors là c'est un système tellement
complexe que personne ne peut faire la
moindre prévision évidemment mais que se
passer des choses
vous avez bien évidemment les
températures extrêmes vers le haut qui
vont augmenter ça c'est pas très
compliqué de le comprendre quand on
chauffe l'ol se dilate et par ailleurs
quand on chauffe la glace elles font ces
deux termes là avons fait remonter le
niveau de l'eau une partie du co2 qu'on
met dans l'air est repris par l'océan
par compensation des différences de
pression partielle et saad sidi philo ce
qui empêche de plus en plus les
organismes qui doivent synthétiser une
partie du calcaire quand on se trompe
dans l'océan s'appelle l'aragonite de
synthétiser l'audi calcaire et ça
démarre au plancton vous avez des
organismes planctoniques qui ont besoin
de synthétiser un petit calcaire en art
un petit squelette pardon en argot dit
on va modifier la différence de
potentiel si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
paul tropiques la différence de
température en l'occurrence ce qui va
modifier la circulation océanique à
large échelle
on va intensifier les ouragans ce qui a
déjà commencé
alors là c'est assez simple à comprendre
le réchauffement climatique augmente la
température en surface mais
corrélativement refroidi la stratosphère
donc vous augmentez gradient verticale
de température donc vous augmenter la
puissance de tous les mouvements
convectifs donc surtout ce qui procède
d'un mouvement convectifs les tornades
les ouragans les orages il est assez
facile de dire qu'il y en aura soit plus
soit qui vont durer plus longtemps soit
qu'ils seront plus étendue soit qu'ils
sont plus intenses et aujourd'hui ce
qu'ils gagnent apparemment c'est
l'intensité il y en a pas plus sont pas
nécessairement plus étendu encore que
par contre ils sont plus violents le
groenland a commencé à fondre et va
fondre totalement ou partiellement
jusqu'à la prochaine entrée en
glaciation l'antarctique de l'ouest est
également menacé il ya un article paru
dans nature très récemment qui explique
que dans les scénarios 3 et 4 degrés
pour dire les choses de manière un peu
simple il ya cinq à dix mètres dos en
plus potentiellement à l'horizon de cinq
siècles alors 5 à 10 mètres dos en plus
je peux vous dire que bordeaux le havre
nantes
lille et ses frappes à lille dunkerque
boulogne etc
c'est un petit sujet est évidemment ça
se passera à un moment où il y aura pas
l'énergie fossile pour reconstruire le
truc trois kilomètres plus loin bref ça
va être un peu rock'n'roll et comme on
fait l'expérience pour la première fois
la seule chose dont je suis absolument
certain c'est qu'on veut on dérape à
venir à l'avancé toutes les conséquences
et comme on ne verra pas venir à
l'avancé toutes les conséquences
une partie d'entre elles nous renverrons
à la logique shadok du début de cet
exposé c'est à dire qu'on comprendra pas
que ça vient de là et donc soit on ne
traitera pas le problème
soit on prendra une mesure qui va
l'aggraver bah oui en ce moment c'est
exactement ce qu'on est en train de
faire avec nos éoliennes et des panneaux
solaires
on ne traite pas le problème et on est
en train de prendre une mesure qu'il
aggrave donc c'est c'est très courant je
veux dire tyrol je peux être d'accord
avec tout ce qu'il raconte mais dans son
bouquin récent il ya une phrase qui dit
quand on s'attaque à un problème nouveau
et complexe
il est absolument évident que dans les
premières mesures que l'on va prendre
une partie seront totalement
contreproductive c'est normal d'accord
la seule parade à ce truc là c'est la
compréhension du problème et là vous
voyez ça fait déjà une heure et demie de
jeu cause et je vous en ai 10 3%
je vais finir ce petit exposé avec
une petite mise en perspective
temporelle vous avez ici un graphique
qui vous met en perspective les deux
problèmes dont je vous ai parlé donc les
émissions de co2 que vous avez sur ce
graphique en fait c'est la consommation
de combustibles fossiles c'est pareil et
comme on tape dans un stock de départ
qui est donnée une fois pour toutes la
consommation issus de ce stock ne peut
faire que ça vous vous rappelez
probablement d'un théorème qui dit que
si vous avez une courbe intégral entre
mois l'infini et plus l'infini est
positive et que l'intégrale existe et
bien à ce moment la valeur moyenne de la
fonction elle est nulle à moins l'infini
nul à + l'infini et ça passe par un
maximum entre les deux c'est une autre
manière de dire que vous prenez une
fonction vous prenez le pétrole
extractible vous êtes borne est
supérieurement par la quantité de
pétrole que vous pouvez extraire de la
croûte terrestre
le stock étant donné une fois pour
toutes vos 300 millions d'années pour en
faire on peut dire qu aux échelles des
temps historiques s'est donnée une fois
pour toutes
donc l'extraction annuelle de pétrole ce
qui est une valeur moyenne comme une
autre c'est nul à moi l'infini du la
plus l'infini et ça passe par un maximum
absolu entre les deux est ce que je
viens de dire s'applique aux cuivres
autant talent ou vanadium aux promos
nickel aux ir cogné hommes et au
germanium tout la seule question c'est
la hauteur du maximum et son horizon
temporel mais sinon tout y passera donc
les émissions de co2 je suis absolument
certain keith b seront un jour la seule
question c'est est ce qu'on leur a
déclenché et gérer ou est-ce que ça se
passera tout seul parce qu'il n'y a plus
assez de combustible fossile où il ya
encore un autre facteur limitant qui
s'applique qui diminue la taille de
l'humanité mais de toute façon il va
arriver le maximum des émissions de co2
c'est un autre chapitre de mon bouquin
qui s'attaque à l'idée qu' il peut y
avoir des émissions croissantes jusqu'en
2100 je ne le crois pas parce que je
crois que l'humanité se contractera sous
l'effet des facteurs limitants avant
2100 enfin l'activité économique humaine
plus exactement ça n'attendra pas de
1100 donc les émissions de co2
baisseront avant 2100 la seule question
c'est est ce qu'on leur a géré pour
l'essentiel est en nous ou est-ce que ça
va nous tomber sur la gueule à
l'occasion d'autres choses qu'on n'aura
absolument pas eu envie d'avoir
mais c'est la seule question je le
répète il ya pas une économie qui va de
mieux en mieux jusqu'en 2100 pendant que
page 3 du journal on vous fait un peu
peur avec un problème pour plus tard un
jour
comme j'ai dit une fois l'avenir devient
le présent donc les émissions de co2
montent et descendent les échelles de
temps qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est que
c'est pas au moment où les émissions de
co2 se mettent à baisser que la
concentration en co2 mais abc donc là en
ce moment on est en train de vous dire
les émissions de co2 plafonnent oui
c'est possible
notamment parce qu'on s'approche d'une
crise économique c'est pas pour autant
que la concentration en co2 a baissé
dans l'atmosphère va continuer à monter
parce que le temps de résidence et un
surplus de co2 dans l'atmosphère se
comptent en milliers d'années on va
continuer à monter la température
atmosphérique va continuer à augmenter
mais surtout la températures océaniques
va continuer à augmenter pendant des
milliers d'années après qu'on ait passé
le pic des émissions et donc le niveau
de l'eau va continuer à monter pendant
des milliers d'années après qu'on ait
passé le pic des émissions alors si on
veut pas si on veut pas voilà la
deuxième boîte cardinal de mon affaire
donc la première c'était énergie pib la
deuxième ses émissions température vous
avez ici un ensemble de courbes qui
s'interprète d'une manière assez simple
sur l'axé des abscisses vous avez les
émissions cumulées en co2 des hommes
entre 1850 et 2100 et en ordonnée vous
avez reliés par la série droite là vous
avez l'élévation de température
planétaire qu'on aura entre 1850 et 2100
donc applications pratiques
à la fin de 2015 nous avons mis deux
mille milliards de tonnes de co2 dans
l'atmosphère tout n'est pas resté à une
partie est passé dans les océans et une
partie dans les écosystèmes
mais par contre ce qui est resté nous
garantit que à la fin du 21e siècle la
température moyenne aura augmenté de 1,2
quelque chose degrés par rapport à 1850
je vais vous le dire nulle autre manière
les 1,5 degré de l'accord de paris s'est
déjà mort ça n'est même pas la peine de
demander au giec ce que pourraient être
les conséquences de cette hausse de
température
s'il ya des gens concernés par cette
affaire dans la salle j'ai toujours été
d'accord avec le giec là je pense qu'ils
viennent d'accepter un mandat qui va
faire perdre du temps à tout le monde et
qu'ils n'auraient jamais dû accepter
j'avais c'est fini fallait y penser
avant
c'est comme si moi je disais tiens à 30
ans j'aurais dû devenir pâtissier je
peux devenir pâtissier à 54 ça c'est
toujours possible à 30 c sur que non
donc les 1,5 degré là c'est cuit si on
veut 2 degrés ça s'est pas encore
complètement cuit mais vous allez voir
que c'est pas tout cuit
ça veut dire qu'on a droit qu à 3000
milliards de tonnes de co2 émis dans
l'atmosphère entre 1850 et 2100 dont
2000 ils sont déjà allés donc ça veut
dire qu'il nous reste pour le siècle qui
vient mille milliards de tonnes à
émettre c'est à dire la moitié de ce
qu'on a déjà émis alors sur le siècle
qui vient de s'écouler
alors que l'humanité était en moyenne
trois fois moins nombreuses c'est ça les
deux degrés je mets au défi quiconque de
m'expliquer que c'est pas récessif
évidemment que c'est récessif évidemment
que c'est récessif heureusement que les
politiques parfois ne comprennent pas ce
qu'ils signent d'habitude je leur en
fait souvent le reproche
pour une fois c'est plutôt quelque chose
qui nous aident si vous regardez à quel
type de trajectoire ça correspond en
gros il faut diviser les émissions par
trois d'ici à 2050
alors non seulement faut pas les
augmenter donc faut pas construire une
seule centrale à charbon supplémentaires
à partir de maintenant rien zéro nada
mais en plus il faut pas les il faut il
faut ferraille est tout ce qui reste et
il faut aller très vite
alors très rapidement quelques petites
indications sur ce qui nous attend
vous avez ici un panorama des émissions
actuelles de gaz à effet de serre actuel
21 % des émissions mondiales c'est les
seules centrales à charbon pour diviser
les émissions planétaires par 3 je vois
pas comment on se passe de mettre tous à
la ferraille donc plus une centrale à
charbon à partir de maintenant plus une
il y en a encore quelques centaines de
giga watts dans le calepin avec des gens
qu'on dit ouais on va quand même
construire ça parce que monsieur borloo
dit vous comprenez les africains ont
besoin d'électricité on va en rajouter
quelque chose peut-être je sais pas mais
en tout cas s'ils ont volé 2 degrés
seuil est c'est pour cent
c'est les centrales à gaz et à fuel 5%
des émissions planétaires c'est les
cimenteries
vous avez encore 5 à 6% qui est la syrie
et avec la chimie et le reste de
l'industrie ça fait douze en gros une
fois que vous avez fait acier ciment
chimie vous avez 80% ou 70% des
émissions mondiales
c'est vraiment très très concentrée sur
l'industrie de base 6% c'est les
chaudières de bâtiments dont
en france les bâtiments ses 28% du co2
parce qu'on chauffe l'hiver qu'on
climatiste pas l'été à singapour le
chauffage l'hiver c'est pas vraiment le
sujet donc ça ça n'existe pas donc en
moyenne
évidemment à ce moment-là climatisation
l'été vous allez l'avoir leila 15% en
gros c'est des transports dans
lesquelles les voitures alors j'ai
arrondi donc le total fait pas 15 6% les
voitures 4% les camions et en gros 2 et
2 les avions et les bateaux
retenez que le parc de camions dans le
monde c'est un problème qui est 10 plus
gros ni plus petit que les cimenteries
c'est un problème qui est ni plus gros
ni plus petit que les aciéries et c'est
le quart du problème que représentent
les centrales à charbon et je peux vous
assurer que ce sera plus facile dans 30
50 se séparer des centrales à charbon en
particulier grâce au nucléaire je vais
dire le gros mot c'est techniquement
possible
se séparer de tous les camions mondiaux
dans les trente cinq ans qui viennent
sans émeute
j'ai un peu de doute donc je vais le
dire autrement
j'ai tout de suite est un peu grossier
les gens qui aujourd'hui refusent de
nucléaire vol la mort de la grande
barrière de corail
la disparition de la base honni et les
émeutes à la syrienne c'est ça qu'ils
veulent c'est respectable mais c'est ça
qu'ils veulent enfin ils veulent
contribuer à ça pour être plus précis
parce que c'est pas juste ça qui va
faire le job 20% des émissions mondiales
c'est l'alimentation retenait qu'en
france les deux tiers des émissions
liées à l'alimentation d'un français
c'est le cheptel bovin donc là c'est
pareil on ne fera rien sans diminuer le
nombre de vaches et comme les éleveurs
font un métier plus difficile que vous
ça veut dire évidemment qu'il faut
augmenter les prix de la viande est pas
un peu c'est plutôt x 3 chez eux
8 % c'est la déforestation qui est un
déterminant amont de l'agriculture soit
dit en passant on coupe des forêts pour
faire place à des champs donc là il ya
deux drivers important la croissance
démographique et le passage à une
alimentation carnée mon ami gaël giraud
qui est chef économiste de l'afd a tenu
ce qui pour un père jésuite est
remarquable le propos très courageux
vous pouvez trouver sur une vidéo qui
traînent sur internet
propos très courageux suivant il a dit
aujourd'hui le premier mandat d'une
banque de développement doit être de
contenir la démographie il a mille fois
raison
il a mille fois raison et enfin 10%
c'est des bricoles d'hier sur le
traitement de l'eau et c'est donc ça ça
doit être divisé par un facteur 3 par un
facteur 3 à 35 ans c'est ça la 2°
d'accord donc si vous êtes pour les deux
degrés vous êtes pour se séparer des
deux tiers de sa dans les trente cinq
ans qui viennent évidemment pas en
rajouter donc on arrête de racheter de
plus en plus souvent des ordinateurs et
des iphone on en rachète de moins en
moins souvent et on rap us ce qu'on a si
vous regardez les intérêts composés qui
sont liées à cette diminution
en gros on est en train de parler de
quelque chose qui doit baisser de
quelques pour cent par an alors vous
avez ici un graphique tout frais sortis
du four
je peux pas dire tout frais tout court
qui vient du chis project dans lequel on
a regardé en noir la variation des
émissions à partir de maintenant si on
suit les hyènes des ses communiqués à
paris donc que tous ceux qui se
réjouissent se réjouissent un peu moins
la seule chose à laquelle se sont
engagés les pays à l'accord de paris
aujourd'hui c'est augmenter leurs
émissions
c'est la seule chose à laquelle ils se
sont engagés pour le moment un accord
or il faudrait les baisser de quelques
pour cent par an à partir de demain
matin
demain matin pendant dix ans demain
matin en bleu c'est si on s'y met à
partir de 2018 et en rouge c'est si on
s'y met à partir de 2025 donc autant
vous dire que ça n'arrivera jamais en
guerre mondiale pandémie et autres
plaisanteries de ce genre même ça j'ai
quand même quelques doutes et en tout
cas si on veut avoir quelque chose qui
se rapproche de ça il faut pas se dire
on se reverra dans trois ans pour savoir
si peut-être on commence à s'exciter
non c'est mort si on fait ça c'est
l'accord de paris est mort
absolument évident petit petit calcul
que je me suis amusé à faire aussi j'ai
regardé sur le xxème siècle à quel
moment est ce que les émissions de co2
avaient diminué sur une année de plus de
5%
donc voilà la variation annuelle des
émissions de gaz et par d'empathie ou de
gaz à effet de serre
et vous avez deux moments où c'est
descendu sous 5% là et là à gauche le
paroxysme de la crise de 29 à droite
l'anéantissement de l'allemagne et du
japon dans 45 voilà là ça descend en
dessous de 5% faut faire ça tous les ans
de manière ordonnée vous mariez pas
sinon c'est le bordel qui gérera le
problème c'est le bordel qui gérera le
problème est avant que les plus jeunes
dans cette salle et mon âge
avant je pense que le président qu'on va
élire l'année prochaine c'est
probablement le dernier avant le pen
s'il continue à penser qu'il va faire
revenir la croissance
en tout cas je suis pas prêt à parier
toute ma fortune sur le fait que ce sera
le pen derrière mais je suis pas prêt
non plus à parier quoi que ce soit sur
le fait que ça soit pas elle donc parce
que l'art entretenir de faux espoirs et
trump c'est évident qui va pas faire ou
plus exactement qu'il ne va pas obtenir
les résultats qu'il a promis donc comme
le disait un excédent éditorialistes des
échos le lendemain de son élection
la seule bonne question maintenant c'est
qu'est-ce qui se passera le jour où les
gens qui ont voté pour lui se rendront
compte que ça va être les premiers à
souffrir dans la trajectoire qui va
suivre
c'est ça les questions aujourd'hui je
finis avec deux ou trois petits éléments
montrant que la meilleure manière de ne
pas avoir de solution c'est de ne pas
voir le problème ou inversement
est-ce que kyoto a servi à quelque chose
peut-être sur le fait qu' il est chaque
année une grand messe et que les gens se
parlent
par contre sur la trajectoire de ce qui
s'est vraiment passé c'est à mon avis
plus intéressant vous avez ici l'europe
et l'évolution du contenu en co2 du
dollar de pipe donc combien en gros j'ai
mais pour transformer à hauteur de 20 $
des ressources naturelles d'accord c'est
ça le dollar de pub et wake on a divisé
par trois yes maintenant je vais voir
les gens qui ont pas ratifié kyoto et je
regarde quelle trajectoire ils ont suivi
sur la même période
voilà la production nucléaire de
l'allemagne
donnez moi la d2 fukushima
vous allez tous vous trompez c'est là
dernier point sur le rapport de l'ademe
et un autre truc vous savez que l on
peut faire 100% nucléaire 100% vénère
pour pas cher alors je me suis amusé à
faire une blague de 3g un conseil pour
tous ceux d'entre vous qui sont en cours
d'étude de ma vie d'ingénieurs je n'ai
jamais vu aucune règle de trois
correctement posé soit infirmée derrière
par une modélisation sophistiqué jamais
je ne sais pas une blague
jamais donc j'ai un conseil à vous
donner qui est le conseil que je donne à
mes étudiants en début de cours toujours
je le redis ici en sortant de secours
vous avez rien compris aux changements
climatiques mais je vous ai fait
comprendre ce que c'était qu'un ordre de
grandeur est une règle de trois je vous
serai utile toute votre vie donc là
c'est exactement pareil je vous propose
une règle de trois et je vous assure que
j'ai jamais vu une règle de trois
infirmée par une quand elle est bien
posée évidemment alors là je me
préoccupe pas de la trajectoire pour
arriver à terme je dis juste je suis
arrivé dans un état où j'ai remplacé le
système français qu en première
approximation je considère comme étant
100% nucléaire par un système 100%
éolien évidemment comme je compte bien
venir à lyon pas que quand il ya du vent
j'ai du stockage dans mon système alors
dans mon système 100% nucléaire j'ai des
centrales qui produisent 70 80 % du
temps dans mon système 100% éolien j'ai
des éoliennes qui en moyenne annuelle
produisent 20 % du temps dit autrement
quand je ramène la production annuelle à
la puissance de l'éolienne
c'est comme si toute l'année elle
tournait à 20 % de sa puissance donc ça
veut dire que pour avoir la même
quantité d'électricité
je dois avoir trois à quatre fois plus
de puissance installée d'accord or au
stockage
après mes réacteurs ils vont durer or
dossiers falsifiés au creusot 60 ans
mais il n'ya pas que cela
donc ils vont durer 60 ans alors que mon
éolienne allait donner pour 20 ans mais
tant qu'elle ça dure 30
peu importe donc j'ai un facteur 2 à 3
donc je vais devoir renouveler mon
investissement une fois dans le courant
de la période
ensuite comme l'éolien et concentrer les
pics de production sont concentrés sur
des plus petites périodes si je veux
récupérer comme j'ai installé quatre
fois plus de puissance
si je veux tout récupérer au moment où
il ya beaucoup de vent mon réseau doit
encaisser quatre fois plus de puissance
ah d'accord donc je vais devoir
renforcer le réseau
et bien ce genre de choses va me coûter
puis par ailleurs pour raccorder plein d
owlient je dois faire plein de trancher
et c'est pas parce que le câble est 1000
fois moins puissant que la tranchée vous
coûte 1000 fois moins cher donc
globalement je vais augmenter les coûts
de maintenance du réseau électrique par
je vais rajouter 50 à 100 % les
allemands ont publié des informations
comme quoi eux c'était 08 dit autrement
pour un investi dans le mode de
production on vénère ils investissaient
0,8 dans l'envié dans l'environnement
électrique permettant aux trucs de
fonctionner après il va falloir que je
fasse du stockage inter saisonniers
parce que il ya plus de vent en hiver je
consomme quand même de l'électricité en
été j'aurais pu mettre du soleil ça
change pas tellement les ordres de
grandeur à laurier 26 panache eux donc
il ya du stockage inter saisonniers le
stockage inter saisonniers ça coûte un
bras une jambe
moi j'ai fait un calcul en construisant
des stades partout donc je peux remonter
l'eau du léman dans les vallées qui sont
au dessus
je suis sûr que les genevois
apprécieront de pouvoir faire de voile
quand on a besoin quand il a trop de
vent justement quand et du vent paf ont
fait remonter l'eau ils peuvent faire
dévoile donc le on pourrait faire ce
genre de truc j'ai fait les calculs ça
coûte un peu cher
en gros ça multiplie tous les
investissements au dessus par deux par
contre le nucléaire coûte beaucoup plus
cher au kilo watt installé surtout si on
dit qu'il faut ceinture et 3 paire de
bretelles et là je gagne quand même un
facteur 3 sauf que si je fais x 3 x 2 et
sera divisé par trois j'obtiens quand
même à l'arrivée je vais devoir
multiplier les investissements par 10 à
20 donc si j'ai un système complet et
j'insiste sur le complet je ne vais pas
juste mon frigo ou ma machine à laver
qui fonctionne quand il ya du soleil du
vent marqué les fabricants de chemise
très content si je fais ma lessive que
quand il ya du vent je vais être obligé
de triplés mon stock de chemise eux vont
être très content sauf qu'ils
fabriqueront les chemises que quand il
ya du vent ce qui va le plus compliqué
bah oui si j'ai 100 % l'éolien pas de
stockage comme ça que ça marche avec la
société qu'on a bâti c'est quand même un
peu sur un peu compliqué donc je suis
vraiment objets stockés et bien à ce
moment le système complet demande dix à
vingt fois plus d'investissements dit
autrement là où je rebâti mon système
français à neuf pour 300 350 milliards
d'euros
si je fais tout éolien stocker j'en ai
plutôt pour 5000 deux années et demi de
pib en récession j'y crois pas une
seconde
pas une seconde
et quand vous regarder dans le détail la
modélisation qui a été le scénario de
l'ademe qui soi-disant est juste un
machin exploratoire etc les trois
hypothèses qui sont vraiment
structurante dans la sphère sont
planqués sous le tapis dans un coin et
vous arrivez vaguement à comprendre ce
qu'ils ont fait en lisant la légende
d'un graphique mal imprimés c'est une
honte
dernier point et je vais m'arrêter là
dessus vous savez que nous vivons en
démocratie vous le savez je vous invite
à en profiter
j'ai engueulé mes enfants qui sont pas
allés voter à la prière de la droite non
pas que je sois droite mais je leur ai
dit vous avez l'occasion d'aller donner
votre avis sur qui vous avez envie de
voir sur la ligne de départ c'est pas un
processus d'adhésion
c'est un processus où voulions archives
est d'accord et je suis sûr que dans la
salle tous autant que vous êtes même si
vous êtes de droite de gauche du haut du
bas ou rose ou je sais pas quoi vous
avez un avis une préférence
vous êtes capable de hiérarchiser les
gens vous avez en face à les exprimer
votre avis parce que si vous ne
l'exprimé pas c'est les autres qui font
à votre place
après vous viendrez pas vous plaindre
qu'ils aient fait les choses d'une
manière qui vous plaît pas donc en
démocratie ce qui compte c'est le
sondage fait auprès de l'électeur c'est
le sondage fait auprès de l'électeur et
l'électeur est roi donc j'ai fréquenté
un certain nombre de conseillers dans
les cabinets ministériels un certain
nombre de députés etc
je peux vous dire qu'ils n'ont pas le
temps de se renseigner sur tout et donc
ce qui va compter avant tout c'est
l'état de l'opinion donc quand ils ont
un sondage de deux pages à gauche et un
rapport complet de 400 pages à droite y
lisent le sondage parce que c'est tout
ce qu'ils ont tant lire dans la journée
et le rapport on oublie alors regarder
un truc intéressant on a demandé aux
français ce qui contribue aux émissions
de gaz à effet de serre alors les
réponses sont justes partout donc c'est
normal de dézinguer nucléaire pour le
remplacer par des éoliennes dans la loi
de transition énergétique et donc c'est
normal que le nucléaire fait de l'effet
de serre on attendait évidemment que
c'est normal
si vous pensez que c'est pas bien de se
décider sur la base d'une information
erronée
eh ben j'ai un conseil à vous donner
mouiller un peu la chemise pour répandre
la bonne information
voilà et là dessus j'ai déjà trop causer
donc je vais m'arrêter
j'ai été un peu long tout le temps pour
les questions merci
[Applaudissements]